Howdy.
It was one of those nights.
Those chilly nights.
Just sends a shiver up your spine.
Thinking about her as the water droplets hit the window.
How it's my fault.
We're in this sticky situation.
But I know... there's just one thing that I gotta do.
And that's find justice.
We need to go grayscale for this.
I thought about it.
Hard-boiled Minto?
I only microwaved you for 30 seconds.
To become this...
Broiled...
I only need...
One second.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome back.
Hello, or welcome in.
Hello.
Spank, thank you so much for the...
Super Tot.
Looking good, boss.
Thanks, Wally.
Um...
A long time ago, I played the first Duck Detective.
Something about salami.
Oh!
It says it right behind me.
Secret salami.
I don't...
So this is the second one.
I don't think you need to know about the first one.
To play...
Or to watch...
There's some recurring characters, but...
Yeah!
Congrats on the surgery?
Huh?
How's the old voice box?
I went to...
The booth spittle yesterday.
And I saw...
The doctor...
And...
I...
Oh...
Skyward!
Congratulations!
Oh my goooooosh...
Oh my god, my first ever...
You guys call it an endoscopy.
I went...
And I was...
I was shaking...
Like a cold leaf...
In fall.
I was like...
And the doctor came in, and he was like, what seems to be the problem?
And I said, my voice.
And my
throat hurts.
And I'm scared.
And he said, okay, miss.
And before he came in, the nurse shoved a pipe down my nose.
That part hurt the most.
And he squeezed, and then it gave me the medicine, the numbing stuff.
I didn't like that one.
Oh my gosh, it almost felt like I was getting a COVID test, you know?
Oh, it was terrible.
And then the doctor was like, okay, well, um, this, this doctor's office is very old.
So, um, I can't have you, I can't put your seat back.
Well, he said, let me try.
And he did.
And it was like, the chair.
And I was like, it's okay.
I'll sit up.
And he was like, yeah, um, the doctor was very nice.
Like an old rollercoaster.
Just like Toad's Wild Ride.
But, um, I was like, I'll sit up.
And he was very nice.
He was like, one of those kinds of doctors that's very, like, deadpan, but they're funny.
You know what I mean?
And, um, and he was like, are you feeling the numbing medicine?
And I was like, doc, I'm really scared.
Look at my hands.
And they were like, like rumbling.
And he was like, he looked at me and he goes, let me spray you again.
And he spray, and I don't know if it was my nerves being so scared or if it was the medicine.
But, um, my vision started to go black.
And I was like, doc, doc, I'm really scared.
And he goes, let me spray you again.
I was like, you're looking a little pale.
I was like, doc, I'm dead.
But also, I'm really scared.
I thought I was going to pass out for a second.
Not going to lie.
Like, for real.
The only time, other than that, that has happened to me, I was also in a hospital, actually.
But it wasn't for me.
I was visiting somebody.
Um, but I was like, and so I sat there, and he was like, okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna put this tube.
And I thought it went through my mouth.
Oh, no, sorry, that is, that went through my nostril.
And I just sat there.
I was like, and I closed my eyes the whole time.
But he also was just like, I don't know if I'll be able to show you.
Because the technology here is really old.
And alas, he could not show me.
And I got no pictures or nothing.
I feel, I feel like I got ripped off.
I got scammed, maybe.
Oh, did he find any gold?
I don't think so.
But I have a constant running, runny nose.
Like, lots of ectoplasm in me, I guess.
And, uh, no, I didn't even get a t-shirt.
But it was nice because the medicine that they put in my nose made the running stop.
But then, he was like, your, your voice box actually looks so healthy.
And I was like, no way.
And he was like, yeah, I see no, no jewels or anything.
Nothing to be concerned about.
And I was like, no way.
No way.
So, yeah.
In the end, it was all good news.
I still will rest for a little bit while longer.
I might cut it a bit short, depending.
But, um, yeah.
Yeah, I got the doc's approval.
He did give me, like, a paper that said, here are my recommended things.
And it was, it was like, don't yell.
I can't help, but I get too excited.
The rest has been doing good.
Yeah, honestly.
I was really, really scared at one point.
Because I was like, I didn't feel like it would ever recover.
No karaoke.
It does, it does say on there, don't, don't sing unless you get prior permission from the doctor.
I'm at work.
Good luck with work.
Good luck, good luck.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Yeah.
So then afterwards, I just kind of sat outside the office for like a good, it was like a good half hour before I felt like I could, oh, before I felt like I could float back to the meded cafe.
Anyway, before I was, it was less wobbly.
Next karaoke stream in the title, doc approved.
Yeah.
Don't sing unless medically necessary.
But yeah, so the only thing after is also once the, once the, I'm glad I didn't stream yesterday.
I thought about it.
I was like, maybe I'll stream to get some of these nerves out after too.
But, um, oh, I, I, my throat really actually ended up hurting.
I think because, you know, there was a, there was a tube down there.
And I also, I also, I guess was so, I had so many nerves that happened.
I was so nervous.
I, I fell asleep at like 7 p.m.
And then I woke up at 1 a.m.
And I was up for like two and a half hours.
And I went back to sleep.
I was like, I was like, I, I exhausted myself.
And now we're here.
Sorry for my long story.
I was in and out so fast though.
I was in.
I actually, I got to the doctor's office.
And they, I sat down and like, maybe a minute later they called me.
And I was like, oh, no, please call somebody else.
I, I, I don't want to be called.
Please.
Give me a second to get my thoughts straight.
And so I was in and the guy sprayed my nose.
And then the doctor came.
And then I was out.
And then I was like, whoa.
Yeah, I was not mentally prepared at all.
I don't even know how I got to the, to the, to the, to the doctor's office.
I missed the turns many times.
I missed several turns.
Because I was so scared.
I was scared.
Yeah.
Oh, fast service.
It was.
Yeah.
And we got good news.
So.
Good news.
Yeah.
She's dead.
I am.
Oh, just thinking about it is making my.
No, making me feel a little woozy again.
Uh, I guess I'm really bad with shots, right?
You would think that as a ghost, I don't have to get shots.
But sometimes I do.
I don't have to get ectoplasm drawn too.
And everything sucks.
But I'm very, very, very, very, very, very bad with shots.
And even just the thought of it can make me feel so woozy.
And so I thought, I think maybe I tricked myself into thinking it was like a shot into my nose.
If you have runniness from your nose going into your throat, you may need some ex-ex-pec-ex-pec-torrent.
Sounds like a wizard spell.
So, I have that problem too and take those now and then I'll look into it.
Thanks, Joshua.
So proud of you for doing the visit.
Beyond the stress of dog visits in general, there's extra level of fear with people shoving things on your throat.
Yeah.
But now I know what to expect, so.
Hmm.
And it wasn't so bad.
I just, you know.
Good.
Congrats on the good news.
Thank you.
I have my physical tomorrow.
I always get anxious about that stuff too.
Please wish me luck.
Good luck, Maddie.
You got your vitamins.
And apparently, eat more fiber.
Yes.
Lots of people don't eat enough fiber nowadays, I guess.
Yeah.
But it happened.
Even though it was yesterday, I could, I still.
I'm like, Right now, just talking about it, like, in past tense, like, Oh, yeah, I did it.
It's over.
Oh.
After, after so long of me needing to get it done.
You stole my heart with your ghostly powers.
Willing.
I'll willingly send the soup as thanks for all the fun streams.
Thank you, Grizzly.
Thank you.
Congrats on the good news.
So happy your throat is doing well.
Thank you.
But next time, somebody needs to join me so I can squeeze their hand.
Okay.
Next time, I need...
Oh, gosh.
I'm getting really...
I need to stop talking about it, I think.
Getting still kind of wobbly.
You volunteer?
I volunteer as tribute.
I like the song in this so much.
How it's like jazzy and detective-y.
But it's got that theremin...
There- there- there- there- theremin?
Is that what it's called?
The musical instrument that goes the...
Wooo!
That one.
My hands get sweaty.
My hands get small.
I mean, it's...
It's not sweat.
I'll be tribute.
The noire ambiance.
I get anxious at the dentist.
You know what?
I...
I have never... I...
Well, I wouldn't want to say never, but I don't feel like I get nervous at the dentist.
Dope!
I've decided.
Next time I go back to Japan...
I'm going to...
Go to...
There's a dentist in Akihabara that's all maids.
And I will go there and get my teeth cleaned.
Wait, wait, wait!
The place is gonna be hella crowded with all of us.
Yeah, right?
Maid dentist.
And I've seen it before in Akihabara, but I never...
Went.
And it's kind of been blowing up a little bit.
Like in...
On...
Social media.
So...
What do you mean you miss me?
I'm right here!
Hi!
Emotional support wisps.
I need it.
Anyway...
Oh yeah, I also...
Sorry, I just...
Cleared my throat.
But I usually mute to clear my throat.
But the doctor yelled at me.
He said, No clearing your throat!
I got in trouble.
So...
I have to stop doing that.
He hee.
Bye bye.
I can't believe I'm still sleepy though.
I slept for so much.
What are you supposed to do?
I...
I don't actually know.
I don't know.
Ah...
I'll go.
Blah blah blah.
That's what I'll do.
Whoa!
Been a good minute since I made an appearance.
I know!
Kanye East.
Glad all is well.
I'm wishing pure positivity and good health.
Should I bring back Minto Healthcare Installments?
No!
But thank you so much for the Akashupa.
Thank you.
Probably drink water.
I have water.
Well, I have tea.
We had several endoscopies and two surgeries.
They're so stressful.
Several?
That sounds so scary.
You're brave.
You're so brave.
63% of Minto's stories involve Minto being terrorized by everyday life.
Well, in my case, it's afterlife.
Which is bad.
But it's funny.
Which is good.
Thanks, Minto.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ezreal.
Anyway.
Shall we start this ghostly glamping adventure?
This is gonna make me wanna go camping, huh?
Would you like dialogue to auto-advance?
Yeah!
Actually, wait.
Story mode.
I can change it, probably.
Life wasn't easy.
I forgot his voice is so...
I was as broke as ever.
It's so deep!
And just when my misery had reached its peak...
Doesn't sound like a duck.
He decided to kick me out of my apartment.
What?!
Thankfully, I had...
found somewhere new to stay.
He's got that bread addiction, right?
What?
No, Hannah still hasn't seen my last twelve messages.
Not the twelve messages.
She rarely responded to my messages after the divorce.
But this...
was really starting to worry me.
What if she was in danger?
I needed to work out what happened to her.
I think she blocked you, dude.
Deductions are a vital part of a detective's work.
Find clue words by questioning persons and inspecting your surroundings.
Enter clue words into blank spaces to solve deductions.
Old flame.
So we know Anna is not replying to my messages because Anna is...
Okay, we gotta find clues.
Anna is in another relationship.
Anna.
The most...
Magnificent swan...
I ever had the lousy luck to fall in love with.
Lousy luck for a duck.
Aiding Mike Tyson's ass!
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
Hey!
I'm not ready to face the world yet.
He's so sad.
Hang in there.
Wait.
Royalty payments.
The only book I managed to finish.
The early bird catches the criminal.
The duck detective story.
Oh!
Three schmark.
Last month.
What is three schmark?
Why do I even bother?
Oh!
Like...
Is that money?
He got like three bucks?
The receipt from the post office.
Sienna.
I did send your glove back.
I'm not that irresponsible.
Irresponsible added to clues.
This guy.
Is kinda sad.
I mean he was sad last game too.
Oh!
Look at that!
Wee!
Oh!
That's all bread under his pillow!
He's still addicted!
Wait.
He has a roommate in this one...
In this like studio apartment.
Where do they...
Oh!
I'm making a mess.
Girl!
Excuse me.
One message from November 9th.
They share a bed.
You still haven't sent back my glove.
Did you think keeping my wardrobe ransom would trap me with you?
We would very much like to not have to think about you and your bread anymore.
Who's we?
No more messages.
Uh oh.
So that's the glove he was talking about.
Use the magnifying glass to find clues and then press E to uncover them.
D.
Oh wait.
Is this their pictures together?
This seems way too intimate.
No.
Look at that.
Their wedding photo.
Happier times.
Sad breakup songs that hit hard.
Not love is fake by sad men.
Oh wait.
June 12th, 2024.
Goose times.
Three teenagers injured when trying to cross sector border?
Is that what this is?
Goose times newspaper.
What else?
Oh here.
Court hearing reminder.
Uh oh.
Wait what's the third thing I'm supposed to find though?
It won't let me click on anything else.
Oh here maybe?
Injured.
I should probably delete these photos.
Oh.
I should be able to figure this out now.
Because...
Anna is...
Injured.
Irresponsible tra...
Oh wait.
Wait.
But it said teenagers.
She trapped?
Because of the glove?
But we sent it back.
She's irresponsible.
I mean though.
Hello.
I'll do the trap.
She feels trapped about the glove.
What?
Wait.
Oh the duck?
Oh we got a new thing.
Irresponsible.
There we go.
Ah.
So that was the issue.
Hmm.
I feel like I've gotten a lot better lately.
She should give me another chance.
You can't force it, Duck Detective.
Oh!
Mr. Duck Detective!
I mean, Eugene.
You're finally up, sleepyhead.
You're rooming with him?
Are you sleeping in your trench coat?
I got you those super comfy pajamas, remember?
He's sleeping in his trench coat.
You should really get dressed.
Sure, sure.
But I just had to come tell you that.
We're going on a surprise trip!
Ooh.
And I bet you can use your deduction powers to figure out where we're going.
Okay.
He giggled.
Wait.
Yeah?
Are those...
bread slices?
Okie dokie!
He doesn't even question.
You know, as long as...
As long as he pays the rent, right?
Frederson.
That was his name!
Frederson...
The Duck Detective is...
No.
I don't think so.
Oh, I wish I could...
I wish I could get rid of it.
Okay.
I don't think there was anything here.
We can go outside now.
That's just good roommate etiquette?
Well, it's bad roommate etiquette to...
He really preferred staying isolated in my room.
To bust to his room, you know?
Rummaging through Frederson's mountain of clutter was the last thing I wanted to do, but...
It seemed that this was how I was going to spend my Wednesday.
What a...
What a pigsty!
I thought you were a duck and a gator!
Was there a pig living here too?
Gross!
Ow!
Oh, gosh.
He's so clumsy.
Wait.
Do those start moving on their own?
This place really is haunted!
This equipment must be worth thousands of Schmark!
He hasn't gone skiing even once.
Hmm.
Skiing.
Okay.
Let's see what we got here.
C-C-C-C-Cutiepie?
Told you this is a work trip, Freddy!
First name.
Freddy...
Please, let me bring Eugene.
He seems a bit lonely.
Also, he loves being by the water.
Okay, so, Cutie Pie is saying that this is a work trip.
Lost Places number 8, Sunny Lake.
Oh, gosh!
What's so scary?
MooTube!
That's why I catch me streaming on MooTube.
Eerie Expeditions.
Okay, wait, but this is like literally...
Teddy subscribed.
This is literally what I watch.
This is literally the same kind of YouTube I watch.
Oh, boy.
You won't believe what we found in this decrepit sanatorium.
Watch until the end.
It's literally my room.
Don't admit that.
Don't admit that to a maid of all people.
Does Mint have a crippling bread addiction?
Maybe not bread.
How did he manage to find a girlfriend?
They've only been dating for a couple weeks.
I guess there hasn't been enough time for her to find out how awful Frederson is.
I always keep track of names in my notebook.
Oh, my God!
Yeah, don't admit that to another woman.
So true, that too.
I don't think you wanna...
I don't think...
I think you would scare off...
Anybody you're trying to woo over...
If you tell them how dirty and gross your room is.
It's important to work out a suspect's name to crack the case.
Enter their first and last name into the slots below their portrait in your journal suspect page.
Freddy Frederson.
We know.
Hmm...
Oh, I'm such a klutz.
Look at all that salami!
Oh, what's this?
Oh...
I forgot...
I pressed Q instead of E!
He's gotta let it out!
Just scream your heart out!
Scream all your worries!
You know when you just go to the ocean and you...
Honk and quack...
To the...
To the horizon?
His newest hobby is skydiving!
Skydiving!
I don't think his snout would even fit in this helmet!
Wait, so we have skiing and skydiving.
What the heck is happening here?
Oh yeah...
Is this his girlfriend?
Rollercoaster.
Near-death experience.
Quack!
Sunny lakeside!
That's the...
That's the video we just saw, no?
Luxurious glamping.
Oh...
Why would you put this in the frame?
Double chin.
Unflattering angle.
How is that a clue?
Thank you so much for the gift.
Why?
Is that a clue?
Aw, look at his little family.
So cute.
This is diabolical.
Why'd you frame this?
Why is he keeping this awful photo of me?
That's what I'm saying.
I think I got everything.
I like how there's more salami here.
I think I got everything except him.
Have you figured it out yet?
I'm working on it.
What's this?
Last night.
About last night.
Oh, yeah.
I heard some strange noises coming from your room.
It sounded like a whale in pain.
Uh...
Yeah.
That's what it was.
I was, uh...
Watching that new show.
Whale Tail.
Nice.
I thought you were having one of your breakdowns.
Oh...
Oh!
Have you figured it out yet?
I'm working on it.
Photo.
Frederson, you'll have to take down that photo of me.
Oh!
Which one?
The one where...
The one where it looks like I have an enormous double chin.
Nonsense!
You always look handsome in photos.
You just don't...
I get it.
Like, uh...
People see what they want to see.
But then you see what you see.
And you're just like, uh-uh.
This isn't it.
Let's see.
What we got here?
Oh!
That's not...
Questionable style!
See, I was looking at the camera.
There we go.
Oh!
Nope.
Hawaiian shirt.
He's got something in his teeth.
In his nose.
He's wearing his glasses.
He's got a big ol' smile.
Insufferable.
So mean.
Like how everyone else sees Minto cute always.
But everybody has a bad angle.
Okie dokie.
Holiday.
Freddy is taking...
The Duck Detective on his trip to go...
Glamping at a...
Tranquil...
Oh, I guess...
A spooky...
Sanatorium!
I don't think you could say Tranquil.
I need to talk him out of this.
Wait.
How is this a work trip?
Frederson!
Did you solve the...
Case?
I figured out you're dragging me on a camping trip I didn't consent to.
Yes.
It's called glamping.
It's very fancy.
Let's get on the bus then.
What if I don't want to?
I spend enough time with you as it is.
Duck Detective, I...
I already paid for everything.
That money is a bit tight right now since...
Since?
You know, you're three months behind on rent.
What?
He doesn't pay rent.
Hmm.
Okay.
I'll go.
Mr. Detective First Name Duck.
The damp air was full of mosquitoes and high expectations.
I want to read the super chats.
I saw them, you guys.
I came here for Frederson.
Once I get a second, I will.
I'm staying for myself.
After all...
Maybe I did deserve a vacation.
But I can't pause it.
Can you smell that fresh forest air, Mr. Duck Detective?
Frog man.
Oh, I smell a bus exhaustion fuel.
You know, they're meant to have some sort of celebrity staying here.
Wait, this is such a good voice for us.
A celebrity?
Oh no, Freddy.
Frederson, please.
Freddy Frederson.
I already brought your suitcase to the tent, by the way.
Thank you, bus driver.
Great.
Let's go and find it.
Okay.
Alright.
Mew Sugar Otsu!
Congratulations for the sugar first day at your new job!
Also...
Happy birthday, Vanilla!
Happy birthday!
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the letter, too.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
You're a baddie from all angles, Minto.
Do I have...
I think I have a good side.
I think I...
I can't tell which side I like more.
I think...
I think this side.
Because you can see my big ol' cheek.
You know?
Did someone say...
Minto cute?
No!
Nice cheeks, Minky.
Nice.
You're talking about my face, right?
What is Freddy mumbling to himself?
Oh!
He's following me!
Oh, gosh.
This game is so ASMR.
You hear it?
Oh, it sounds so good.
Sonny Lake.
Number one haunted camping site, according to TripAlpaca.
You can't trust the reviews on that site.
Haunted...
This guy, I like his voice.
Is, uh, it still camping if you're staying in a cabin?
Oh, we're in a cabin?
Fancy.
Clumsy duck detective.
Have you noticed my new shirt?
I have.
Yes.
Frog has a point.
Do you like it?
Guys, should we be nice to Freddy?
Or...
What do you say?
You guys like his new shirt?
His Hawaiian shirt?
Um...
Yes.
The...
The colors...
Complement you?
Really?
You always know what to say, Mr. Duck Detective!
Aww...
Why is he such a...
He's such a...
A grumbler.
He shoots.
He scores!
Wait, you have something else to say to me?
This is so great, isn't it?
A holiday with you and me.
And your girlfriend.
Oh, right.
Right.
Wait.
He doesn't get scared again.
That is so funny.
We spooked him.
Okay.
Into sunny lakeside.
Oh, my God.
I'm a reasonable rodent, but three camping chairs and a table stolen just like that?
My client is threatening to leave if you don't fix that broken toilet!
Good Lord.
But I'm telling you, this place is haunted.
The ghost is moving things around all the time.
That's the whole premise of Sunny Lake.
Ridiculous.
I don't think Duck's caught on yet that the girlfriend's the actual third wheel.
A theft.
That was definitely something I had to investigate.
A case.
I also wondered what Fredderson's partner was like.
Oh.
Who would date him voluntarily?
I needed to find out who she was.
Lots of people have different tastes.
Oh, hey.
Let me introduce you to my girlfriend.
No.
I mean, no.
Not necessary.
But didn't you just say that you wanted to meet her?
Work out her identity.
Myself.
Oh.
Of course!
Exciting!
Oh, he wants to figure it out himself.
So-and-so is the blank of the campsite.
So-and-so is a blank of the military.
So-and-so is blank's assistant.
What about girlfriend?
What about Freddy's girlfriend?
June 7th.
Six nights.
Eisenman.
Okay.
Well, wasn't he just talking about how he wanted to meet her?
And then he's like, no!
June 8th.
Five nights.
Reh.
Reh Redact.
Stumperton.
Frederson and McQuacklin!
That's us!
Wait, where's the girlfriend?
Hmm.
This looks like it'll come in handy.
I should question these people about their stay at the camp.
Hmm.
Booking list.
Get her!
Okay.
Clumsy duck detective at it again.
He even chuckles after.
So cute.
Oh.
Let's see what we got here.
Someone's diary.
Ooh!
Are we the girlfriend?
It almost sounded like it was screaming in response to that.
The girlfriend exists, right?
Right?
The girlfriend is real and not just one of those apps that like...
You talk to and...
There's like a...
AI girlfriend that talks back to you.
Love Plus.
Guest...
July...
2002.
Two years ago.
Food is substandard and the weather is horrible.
Sorry for yawning.
I don't know why I yawn so much all the time.
I'm hoping this will be improved next time.
Colonel...
Oh!
It's the Eisen...
Eisenman guy.
Why?
I want...
A s...
Toby.
I thought it was gonna say, I wanna go home.
Wait, what else did we miss?
Oh.
Colonel?
Oh, he's Colonel.
You're his girlfriend waifu.
He's a member of yours.
Oh.
Freddie!
Some people will try their hardest to find something to complain about.
Uh oh, that's a lot of mail.
Someone hasn't checked the mailbox in ages.
It says...
Dinkle.
Dinkle!
Alright, so maybe...
Oh no, we can't...
We can't change...
We can't add Colonel Eisenman yet.
Hello!
Dinkle book.
Hi, Piminto!
Yay!
Tonight, I will recount the tragic tale.
Of the haunted sanatorium...
For all of you.
So...
Please, don't miss it.
Exciting.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's see.
Let's search her up and down.
Oh god, she's tired.
Oh no, she's sweaty.
She's nervous.
She's sweating.
Sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff.
Stop!
This is a sniff-spection.
Everybody!
Arms up!
Oh!
Once more for good measure.
Yup!
I'm noting down your stink.
Thank you for participating.
You're free to go.
You are free to go.
She's got a watch.
A bracelet.
Evil, evil eye.
She's got...
What is that?
Ripped tight.
I just...
I wouldn't say neglectful.
Okay.
Gosh.
A little harsh there, Mr. Detective.
Interrogate about this.
Anything you can tell me about Sunny Lake campsite.
Usually the campsite is mostly empty, but this week, I got six bookings at once?
This...
Influencer is already paying off.
See, Amelia?
You're not a failure after all.
Her name's Amelia.
I see.
Thank you, Amelia.
Can we go in here?
Stop!
That area is not for guests.
Oops.
Amelia.
Maybe we don't know the last name yet.
I think I've...
Oh, I'm walking through the pond.
I'm causing...
I'm really just...
Causing a lot of...
Commotion here.
I think we can go this way.
Amelia ReZero.
Sorry.
I love Amelia.
Oh my gosh.
They're trying to boil somebody alive in there.
Did you see that?
A rising tension.
Mired the cool evening breeze.
I may be here for a while yet.
At least I had my emergency bread stash waiting for me in my trench coat.
He's addicted...
To the wheat.
Tricky deductions might require new perspectives.
Press H to get additional guidance at any time.
You can check the map in your book to see if you've missed any clues in the world.
If you want to look at a piece of evidence again, you can quickly access and enlarge it with the evidence tab of your book.
The hint button.
Oh!
Look at that!
That thing is going crazy!
Is that a...
Jacuzzi?
Oh!
I have a crippling red addiction.
I didn't break my swimming shorts.
I prefer...
I prefer rice.
Hmm.
It's locked.
This one's unit number one.
Like I know hot tubs like, you know, they're...
They're hot.
But I don't think they're supposed to boil you.
I think they're just supposed to...
You know...
They're supposed to bubble.
Hold on.
I want to go look at number four.
Oh, here we go.
I didn't realize it was on a platform.
How cool is this tent?
Now we can finally have some one-on-one time together.
We live together.
I see you every single day.
I know, I know.
But this time we can have pillow talk.
Talk about all the deep stuff.
Like...
Why you never take off your hat?
It's a part of him.
I'm not ready to talk about that.
It's...
It's his signature hat.
Wait...
Isn't pillow talk...
What we got in here?
For Katya.
Plushie.
Ooh...
It's like...
Not Pikachu.
Baboon's Bribery.
Detective Novel.
The early bird catches the criminal.
Oh, he's got his book!
Oh, that's him asleep.
And...
Freddy taking a picture.
I don't think he's safe there.
You took my book with you?
Always!
You've read it five times already.
And...
I discover new things every time.
Hmm...
It says...
Unit number two.
It's locked.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna snoop through someone else's stuff?
First name...
Toby!
It's Toby and...
What is that?
Braces cleaning kit!
Okay, anybody with braces we know is Toby.
If found, return to Matilda Eisenman.
Never mind.
Maybe...
This is...
This has gotta be Toby.
Wait!
People with braces can't have gum?
Magicorn Adventures.
Ooh...
Mouch mania.
They...
They got a big old chomp into that...
To that gum.
That takes me back to when I had braces as a kid.
It's not Pikachu.
It's...
It's a bouch.
It's a mouch.
Okay, let's go talk to the people now.
Hello.
The manager at this campsite is a disaster.
Should I call the plumber myself?
What's happening?
That will take forever.
Arno won't be happy at all.
Arno... Huh?
Stop staring at me!
I need to concentrate.
Arnode?
Is that what she said?
Let's investigate your...
Oh, gosh.
She angry.
Intense expression.
We're investigating your body.
Give me one moment.
Ooh, the hand on the hips.
What's that?
A bruise!
Interesting.
What's on your little toesies?
What'd I miss?
I like how the nose is...
It's so freaky looking.
Oh?
What did I miss?
Something in your pocket?
No?
Your toesies?
Is that...
Yeah, RTX on meme.
Horns unusual.
Why is that unusual?
Can I ask why you chose to come to this camping site?
I'm here for work.
This isn't the kind of place I come to by choice.
Wait, work?
Is this who I think it is?
But he would recognize her, no?
He would be like, that's my girl.
That's who I...
I'm in trouble with.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
They have this sketchy capybara staying here.
Probably jobless from the looks of it.
I complain to the management, but they don't seem to care at all!
What if something happens to my son?
He's too juvenile.
He wouldn't stand a chance.
What's with this capybara slander?
Capybaras are so chill.
What are you even?
I can't even tell what animal you are.
A beaver?
A wombat?
What the hell are you?
Hands behind, back, upside.
He's got no tail if he's a beaver.
Thick boots prepared.
Whistle bossy.
A gopher?
Then he would have a whistle in his teeth.
I can't believe someone took my camping equipment!
Oh wait, there's...
What do you make of this campsite?
This place has really gone down the drain in the past years.
So many animals that are just generic...
At least this year, we don't have to book the caravan anymore.
Thanks to my promotion!
Your promotion?
Oh!
Are you the colonel?
Let's go this way first.
I shouldn't wander off just yet.
Just kidding.
I need to find out which one is Frederson's girlfriend.
Oh!
I think we found her!
No?
Uh...
Katya?
I don't know the last name though.
And then this might be...
Wait...
Uh...
Isaman, maybe?
Capybaras are deceptively bloodthirsty.
A capybara killed my father!
Your father...
Probably...
Um...
Was soaking in an onsen.
Eh...
Is there anything else around here?
Maybe I can go to this side?
I shouldn't wander off...
I need to find out...
Frederson's girlfriend...
Okay, hold on.
Today's like the worst day to be sleepy about...
With this kind of game, you know?
Um...
What was the list?
So either Stumperton...
Fenton spent the morning in the yard...
Eggie!
What happened?
I hope you're okay!
What the heck?
Not the concussion!
I think I'm gonna make you have...
Beaver dreams!
Yeah, the jazzy tunes are so chill!
You're right!
Okay, Matilda Eisenman...
So this guy is probably...
Uh...
Arnod Eisenman...
Wrong!
Toby?
No, I was gonna say no.
Wait, are you...
Matilda?
My...
My bad.
My bad, Colonel.
So...
What was the...
What was the list?
There's Stumperton and...
Reh!
Rehren...
The name cuts off!
Thanks for the...
Thanks for the gifted!
Is it Reh?
Yes.
Do we need to get Amelia yet?
Well, I don't think...
I mean, I think Amelia works here...
So she wouldn't sign the guest log, no?
What's this?
Oh!
What do you think of...
Katya Rey?
Katya Rey!
She acts so important!
I'm not even sure what she does, really!
Mm-hmm.
What do you think of...
Matilda Eisenman?
She's crazy!
She has those terrifying eyes!
Keeps ranting about her new rank, or whatever...
No, but aren't you, like, girlfriend?
I don't have to be her son.
Hold on, maybe we can...
No?
It's all blanked out.
Wait.
Do I have to get Amelia...
Oh, wait.
Do I have to do Amelia?
Oh, the Dinkle.
There we go.
Wait.
Do you need to...
Do I...
No?
Oh, you!
Anything you can tell me about...
Amelia Dinkle?
I know she tries, but...
She's terrible at her job!
Reh is German for dear?
No way!
She's been going off the rails with her healing crystals and whatnot.
They're not exactly bringing her luck, are they?
Okay.
Well, I figured out the girlfriend.
Oh, wait.
There's some stuff here.
I missed it.
Survival Handbook 3rd Edition.
Tips from Lieutenant Lemmy.
Rank Lieutenant.
You can use thick prescription glasses to create a fire!
Thanks, Lieutenant.
Tips from Colonel Grant.
Colonel...
Make a tea out of pine needles for a source of vitamin C.
Hey!
Is that good?
Is that real?
Tips from...
Brigadier Wilmer.
Brigadier?
He looks the exact same.
On and off.
Never drink your pee.
Hey.
Can I call you Wilmer?
Desperate times.
Call for desperate.
Tell that to...
Mr...
What's his name?
Bear...
The guy.
That guy that drank his pee.
Infamous for it, even.
Bear...
Gorillis.
Was he wrong?
Are you really not supposed to drink your pee?
Oh, no!
What?
You're not supposed to drink your pee?
I'm not even going to ask.
Oh...
Fr...
Freddy?
I mean, like, you're not supposed to probably, but like...
If you...
Are so desperate for hydration?
There's not much you can do, no!
What can you tell me about...
Katya Ray?
She and the person she's sharing the tent with are very...
Secretive.
She's been asking me to provide security.
W...
What does that even mean?
Not even then?
Much like alcohol, it only makes you thirstier.
Oh, so it's like the...
Seawater.
The saltwater...
Like...
Conundrum.
Where you drink the saltwater and you're like...
Oh my god, I'm more thirsty than not!
I see...
But what if your mouth is just really dry?
Snaps, thank you so much for the pig!
Thank you!
Can I leave now?
I shouldn't wander off.
I need to find out.
Wait, how am I...
Wait, maybe talk to Freddy.
No?
Am I missing something?
Oh, here.
I just noticed the...
This is open.
Never mind, it's locked.
This one is...
Unit number three.
And we looked at that one.
Oh.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
So, we have...
What's her name?
Amelia?
Amelia Dingle...
Wait.
Is the...
Manager...
Potentially.
I think Katya is the...
Influencer's assistant.
And then Matilda...
Is a colonel.
No!
Not a colonel!
Even higher than the colonel!
Oh, because...
Yes!
She was the colonel!
And then she got the promotion.
That's right.
Did any of them look like a chair thief though?
Yeah, yeah.
She had the promotion.
Anyway.
Now I should get back to deducing the identity of Fredderson's girlfriend.
Yes, yes.
The girlfriend.
Katya is Freddy's girlfriend because her...
Name is on a plushie he bought.
Easy peasy.
Katya the deer is Fredderson's girlfriend.
How did that happen?
So judgmental!
So...
You're the mysterious girlfriend.
He figured it out all by himself, Katya!
And...
You are?
The one and only...
Duck Detective!
Is it one of those, like, opposite attracts?
You're the guy that keeps ordering cheese toasties from Freddy's account.
But I...
You told her!
We're boyfriend and girlfriend, of course we tell each other everything.
Oh my god.
Katya!
There you are!
The water...
Is...
Gold!
How am I meant to keep up my skin routine with this ice-cold water?
I was just talking to you!
I don't want to hear it!
Fix it!
Now!
Oh!
Oh, it's blue!
Oh no!
Hooray!
That's why I think they're opposite the track, no?
Very important question, Minto.
Have you seen K-Pop Demon Hunters?
I have not yet!
But I know the one song.
Because I hear it everywhere.
The golden song.
Actually, I've heard a couple of the songs.
I...
I don't like how the guys look in the... in the... in the movie.
Yeah, Soda Pop.
That's the one that... I don't like the way the guys look.
They look...
They look kind of freaky.
Why is their head so big?
It feels like Code Lyoko.
I don't like it.
The guys are kind of meant to be parodies.
Oh, really?
But there's the one song, Golden.
I really like that one.
This is ours.
We get the shabby one.
Right?
Yeah.
So, but is this Freddy or Duck Det...
I guess it's under Freddy's...
Oh, Freddy and Duck Detective.
What the...
Okay.
Um...
This one is...
Number three.
I don't...
Well, they said she's really secretive.
But she is staying with someone.
So that would be Katya.
And then here...
Is, I guess, Toby.
Toby.
We don't have Toby.
And then...
Have I seen this other one?
No.
And then more suspects.
Let's say...
Oh, okay.
We don't know anybody else yet.
So...
We gotta go and talk to some people.
We gotta go.
We gotta investigate.
This one.
Why isn't Freddy staying with his girlfriend?
I think cause she's staying with this guy, no?
The influencer?
Right outside the party.
Okay.
Let's investigate you.
Oh.
Perfect skin.
Vein?
Asari has good genetics.
Oh my god.
I don't know if that's Vein.
A chess fan.
Fancy watch.
Okay.
Everything else looks the same.
Yeah, we already deduced that.
Oh, he's a streamer!
Uh oh.
Oh, he's a streamer.
What can you tell me about Amelia Dinkle?
She gets it all wrong.
All of it, I'm telling you.
Jacuzzi?
Too hot.
Bed.
Too soft.
Well...
The toilet.
Unusable.
Actually, I think this guy is in the fancy one with the jacuzzi then, no?
Why did you decide to come here?
Someone is very nosy.
Are you from the press?
The press.
No!
I'm the duck detective!
Never heard of it.
Duh!
I'm the duck detective!
Yeah!
Like, isn't it...
Oh!
Mr. Duck Detective, I...
I know it's none of my business, but...
Back at home, you keep getting those government letters.
Tons of them!
And they look pretty scary!
Eh...
Not now, Freddy!
I'm on the toilet!
Freddy goes straight into the trash.
Mr. Detective, I'm starting to learn why your girlfriend has left you.
This toilet is making weird noises.
Tax evasion?
Sounds like it's broken.
Broken toilet added to clues.
Um...
Mr. Duck Detective?
Where did you put your suitcase?
I didn't bring one.
You're not gonna change clothes for two days?
Hmph.
Should be fine.
How is it that...
Freddy makes...
Duck Detective look normal?
Or, I mean, the opposite.
How is it that Duck Detective makes Freddy look normal?
Huh?
Stop coming!
Let me take a souvenir photo of us!
You already took one on the bus.
Oh, don't be silly!
We should take one here as well!
I really don't.
Cheese!
Wow!
What a smoldering look, Mr. Duck Detective!
This one's going on the fridge!
Wait, can I make a smoldering look?
Smoldering is not sm...
It's like a...
Like that?
Was that smoldering?
Why am I hard-boiled?
The camera loves you!
Give me more!
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna look it up.
What's a smoldering look?
In...
Okay.
This is what Google says.
A smoldering look generally refers to a sexy, intense, and sometimes mysterious gaze.
Often implying a hidden passion or desire.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Like Eugene from...
From Tangled.
I feel like I'm just angry.
Maybe like that.
Okay.
I'm done being sexy.
Oh, what's this?
Ooh!
Symbols are cryptic.
La-la-land.
A password.
Okay, let's see.
That's a...
That's a wheel.
Wait, how do I...
I can't...
I won't let me...
I won't let me change it.
That's key.
And that's a squiggle.
So none of those are L.
L, L, L.
I wonder what that means.
That's just your life, Dr. Detective.
Not a single W inside.
Is Minto recreating the scene from Jumanji?
Wait, I don't know it.
His building looks way older than the rest.
The door is locked.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, these are showers, right?
Oh.
Oh, they connect.
Wow.
Sexy.
Did I get everything over here?
I think so.
I meant hello.
Group showers.
Yeah, I remember...
I remember summer camp.
Listen, it wasn't that many cheese toasties.
All right, all right.
There's a scene where someone gets peed on.
Really?
I mean, they've already talked about pee.
I guess we'll see.
The capybara!
Is that Toby right there?
The pale moon's reflection shimmered seductively from the glassy surface of the lake.
There was more to this campsite than met the eye.
And I had to dredge up the murky truth.
Dredge.
Can I
go down the slide?
Whee!
Wait, it's so sexy here.
Ugh, this is so calming, isn't it?
Yeah, just like Shrek.
Make all your worries just fly away.
Yeah.
Frederson, those court letters that I've been receiving, they're not a big deal.
Are they?
Duck detective, you need to respond to them!
I did a hoogle search and...
Not hoogle!
It said you could go to jail for that.
He'll lose his detectiving license.
You'll never detective again in this town!
Or ever.
Ooh, that's a knife.
Someone's been doing some wood carving.
The whittling knife has an engraving.
It says...
Theodore.
Are all the chipmunks here?
That old building is a tourist attraction?
That's spooky.
It's pretty famous.
I've watched so many mootubers break in at night and explore it.
It looks very spooky and dangerous.
Yeah.
One time, a floorboard broke, and one of them broke their ankles.
Exciting.
I love a good...
You know, fear.
A badge.
Military.
A lock.
Combination lock.
Inaccessible.
Heart.
Password hint.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I noticed that, too.
That the heart is also the same, where the heart had...
Or the LLL had a heart, too.
Hmm.
That heart seems out of place.
I don't think I can crack this just yet.
Hmm.
Hello, kid.
Do you want to see my magicorn cards?
I have this super strong combo for harmadillo.
Wow!
This card instantly shuffles in a chomp?
That's so OP!
Redesen, we have more important things to do.
Why does it sound so perfect as a little kid?
Right?
Like, my goodness.
You want to see my magicorn cards?
Oh, goodness gracious.
Braces.
Crooked teeth.
Oh, God.
He's got just the tiniest little...
Fashion attempt.
Tiniest strand of hair ever.
Orthopedic shoes.
Misaligned feet.
Toby!
Oh, Toby.
Oh, goodness.
Toby looks way cuter without the magnifying glass.
Do you have any information about Matilda Eisenman?
She says we have to go fishing, but...
I really don't want to.
Where did this accent come from?
She says we have to go fishing.
Are you enjoying your trip?
Mom takes me here every year.
It's so boring.
I'd much rather go to my friend's place.
Okay, Peppa.
Get out of here.
All right, mysterious capybara.
Look how similar these berries are.
Which of these three do you think are edible?
I really don't care.
Master Detective Minky on the case.
No, no, no, no, no, no, wait.
This one.
Wrong-o.
No, all of them are poisonous.
Oh, dang.
In the post-apocalypse, you would have died a horrible, slow death.
Does this kid have three different beings?
Oh, no.
They like switched up on him.
What kind of character they want him to be.
All right, capybara.
Whoa.
He's got some intense eyes.
Gray beard.
He's old!
Some people gray faster than others.
Stra- Stra- He just...
He's...
A growing boy!
Do you have any information about Matilda Eisenman?
She can be charming if she wants to be, but...
She has a bit of a...
An unhealthy attitude.
She's the one that called you creepy.
What do you make of Emilia Dinkle?
Oh, she's lovely, isn't she?
I don't know much about her, but...
She seems like a...
A genuine soul.
Genuine soul.
Haven't been able to catch as many streams lately, but I hope you're staying very hydrated.
I haven't.
In fact, I'm going to sip to that.
Thank you!
Oh, you changed your hat.
You changed your hat.
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for dropping by!
Why have you decided to come here?
Oh, uh...
Just, uh...
Traveling.
Enjoying some me-time in between jobs.
But there's this one guy.
Benoit was his name.
He's really getting on my nerves.
He yelled at me to hurry up when I was on the toilet!
Only for him to squat there for 20 minutes!
Rude!
Alright, what do we got going on here?
Is this Benoit?
Oh, we don't know yet.
We know, though, that this is stinking Toby.
Toby Eisenman!
Is this Theodore?
Benoit!
Okay, oh, what else can we do?
Arnaud?
Wait, who is this again?
Oh, I got it!
But I don't remember.
Someone mentioned it and I don't remember why.
More suspects.
Okay, Toby...
Is the child of...
Uh...
Gosh, there's so many names already.
Matilda.
Yeah.
Blank has no friends.
The duck detective has no friends.
Tomorrow have a work trip.
Wish me good luck, boss.
Tuxedo cat!
Good luck!
It's a blank...
Wait...
Oh, it's a blank influencer!
Um...
Travel influencer?
Oh, no.
Chess influencer, maybe.
Oh, what's your name?
Arnaud?
He has Freddy.
Oh wait, but then Arnaud is gonna be...
The...
VIP guest.
Okay, wait.
So now I need to figure this out.
Um...
He has Freddy.
He shouldn't.
Freddy's too good for him, honestly.
Um...
Trying to work backwards.
No knife?
No magicorn?
No job?
Matilda accused Theodore of being jobless.
That's true.
That is true.
Oh my gosh!
That really was the case.
Of course, it's that pompous guy who gets the VIP tent.
What did you expect of you?
What even is a chess influencer?
He can...
Checkmate real good.
I don't know how to play chess, but I watch some chess influencers.
Actually, sometimes.
There's one girl, she's a model.
And she plays chess.
And isn't that just so hot?
Arnaud?
I don't think Katya's staying with him.
No!
Katya's in here, right?
And then this is...
Toby...
And Matilda.
Wait, chess...
Chess influencers are real?
Yeah, they're like chess masters.
And me!
The duck detective!
I'm also staying here.
Um...
Okay, hold on.
Who did we not assign?
You think Theodore's with him?
No, there's no way.
Unless...
Katya was just hanging out here.
It could be that she...
Okay, hold on.
Dandan, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Ooh!
What is your relationship with Arnaud Benoit?
Arnaud Benoit, Ben...
He's an incredibly difficult client.
Taking him to his tournaments is fine, but...
Going on holiday is a nightmare.
Yesterday, he wanted me to add rose syrup to his rose shampoo.
Ew!
So he can have more rose per rose.
He drives me absolutely insane!
Ugh...
He...
He's me well, though.
Okay, what about Theodore?
How do you feel about...
Theodore Stumperton?
Stumperton.
He's a strange one.
He arrived here with three rattling suitcases.
But what does he need all that stuff for?
Hmm...
Three rattling suitcases, huh?
I think I saw, too, that...
That, uh...
This kid had something lit up.
Yeah.
Can you tell me anything about Arnaud Benoit?
Arnaud Benoit?
What?
He always talks to himself, but never with anyone.
That seems very lonely, doesn't it?
What?
What is your accent, kid?
What do you know about Theodore Stumperton?
The Uncle Capybara is so fun!
He's the only one that plays Magikorn with me!
Is it because he's a streamer?
He only knows how to talk to chat, maybe?
Yikes.
What do you think about Toby?
What can you tell me about Toby Eisenman?
He seems like an alright kid.
I'm not sure what that magical corn is all about, but...
We all had our fixations as kids, right?
Totally.
Magical corn.
Let's go.
I can't figure out who's in this one, then, if it's not her.
Hmm.
This one is you...
You know, unless it's...
Unless it's...
What's his name?
So if it's, uh...
But, wait, then I...
Wait, but I got this one right, no?
Oh wait, just kidding.
Uh, so it's Theodore...
And then it would be Katya.
Okay, there we go.
That's where people were staying.
Having this untangled will help the future.
Why is she in his yard, then, huh?
I-I-Excuse me!
Can I please have attention?
Y-Y-Your attention, I mean.
It's time for the ghost tour.
Yippee!
Please come to the sanatorium ruins by the lake.
Okay!
You don't have to, but...
No, I want to.
Please come.
Yes.
Ghost tour, ghost tour.
What is this nonsense about ghosts?
But ghosts do exist!
Mm-hmm.
I've had one who would return my Rubik's Cube any time I lost it, and put it under my bed!
Ohhhh.
Freaky.
Mom said I'm not allowed to go on the ghost tour.
The ghost tour.
What are you doing here, then?
Well, she's not here, so...
What is our no doing?
Heh.
Oh, that's...
Is this all that's coming?
Not everyone came.
Th-that's okay.
No problem at all.
Follow me!
Yippee!
What you will see in just a moment is the abandoned Sunny Lake Sanatorium for tuberculosis.
Not the tuberculosis.
Many years ago, a terrible sickness crossed the land.
It was swift and methodical as a saboteur weakening the body and trapping the mind, and spreading with the ease of a smile.
Ohhhh.
No one left.
The people acted quickly, building facilities and places of remote beauty to store the ill, until they healed and returned to the cities.
Or worsened.
And returned to the earth.
Ooh!
Spooky!
Patient 12 had been a diplomat.
She'd spent her life in glorious motion, surrounded by crowds.
Oh.
When she caught the disease, they took her to a sanatorium on the edge of a lake.
And isolation in a lonely bed felt like a form of personalized hell.
Ahhhh.
The other patients had feeble routines.
They shuffled to the windows, drank imported teas.
Watched waffles crash and die against the rocks that lined the edge of the lake.
Rocks that reached upwards like grasping hands.
Ooh.
Patient 12 did nothing but watch the shadows waltz over her bedroom ceiling to mark the passing of each day.
And miss her son.
And wished that he would come and visit to steal her away from this picturesque, forsaken place.
Early one morning, Patient 12 noticed a new shadow.
A shadow in the shape of her son.
Freaky.
And she knew that he had come to rescue her.
And she knew it was important to be discreet.
So, quietly, she dressed.
But you have TVs.
And quietly, she climbed out of the window.
She's gonna cause the...
She followed him across the ground.
And over the zombie apocalypse.
And to the cliffs.
Ma'am, you're not in there for no reason.
And quietly, she reached for him.
And quietly, she found that he was not there.
And the rocks that lined the edge of the lake.
The rocks reached upwards to catch her.
Like grasping hands.
Oh my god, that transition.
And they say that she picked herself up.
And dusted herself off.
And climbed slowly back to the top of the cliff.
Huh?
Unaware.
Oh.
That she was dead.
She died.
They say when the fog rolls in, she's there.
Still searching for her son.
Aww.
And that if you are a young boy, you may feel a grasping hand.
Cold against your own.
And you might feel the tuberculosis.
Quickly.
Before it wraps itself around your wrist.
Ooh.
And doesn't.
Let.
Go.
Freaky.
Hmm.
So, yeah.
Pretty spooky, right?
Spooky.
Oh, sorry.
I'm hungry.
What was that?
I know what that was.
That was a ghost scream.
Ah!
Oh, sorry.
Can we go back now?
My...
My tent!
Katya!
You won't believe this!
Uh-oh.
Someone vandalized my tent!
Uh-oh!
You don't have anything under control, do you?
Damn!
You've been specifically asked for more security.
Th-that's...
I...
G-ghost activity is beyond my control!
We won't be coming back!
That's for sure!
Ooh!
Um...
I would like to file a complaint with your manager.
I needed to investigate the VIP tent!
How...
Did they interview her after this?
How did they know?
Seems like all of the witnesses died.
Right!
How did they...
Well, you know, just them ghostly tales and all.
I will need a vacation after this.
Oh!
I'll take you somewhere nice.
I...
Do they like each other?
Or...
I wonder...
This place is so cool.
To be honest...
The scariest thing about that ghost story was the tuberculosis.
Yeah...
Uh...
I heard they sometimes would remove ribs or a whole lung to try to keep people alive!
Ugh!
Too much information!
It's history, duck detective.
I can't tell if some of these are...
I guess that's...
A ghost, huh?
I guess that's orange.
This is why I always say you can never be too prepared.
I feel like they should've made it red or something.
Like, I can't tell if...
I can't tell if this is orange, you know?
Or...
Of everything else is...
It's hard to tell.
It's hard to tell!
Since Mito likes detective stuff, do you watch detective anime like Conan?
Yeah!
I used to be up to date on Conan, actually.
You're a detective!
Right?
Uh-huh.
That's right!
Provet!
Oh!
Um...
He has a magnifying glass!
Yuck!
Although, you should really get some proper glasses, Mr. Duck Detective!
Oh!
Your eyesight is terrible!
Those are expensive!
Aww...
He can't afford his glasses!
All this ruckus!
I'll bet it's for nothing!
Why is everyone hanging out in the Capybara's yard?
I don't understand.
What can you tell me about Toby Eisenman?
Ah, he's such a smart young boy, isn't he?
I hope he drops that magician corn obsession soon, though.
I'm afraid he will become too nerdy.
I think it's very important for parents to guide their children!
I was obsessed with...
A magic corn equivalent when I was...
A wee wisp.
And I turned out just fine!
Too nerdy!
Oh!
Take a dip in the jacuzzi!
Oh yeah!
I feel my organs boiling alive!
I turned out just fine!
Right, guys?
Uh...
Teeheeheehee!
The longer I lived, the more it seemed that life was ultimately just unfair.
Was it vandalized?
Or was it always like this?
Yeah!
There you are!
You said you're a detective, correct?
Correctamono!
Find out why anyone would do this to me?
I'll do my best!
I just want to play as he call it the chase!
Me too!
Vandalism!
And the deviant!
Oh!
Spoilers!
Someone decided to...
Bribe...
The blank...
Blank!
Wee wee wee!
Wee wee!
Guys, give me a second!
I think I'm gonna go grab some coffee actually!
My eyes feel so heavy!
Sorry, I feel like I'm so tired lately.
Lemon Hermit, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
I made you an elf deck.
For a Magicorn?
Thank you!
Yeah, I'll be right back!
And I'm gonna grab some more tea too.
I'll be...
One second.
Because I had...
Two feet earlier.
I just didn't finish it.
So...
Um...
I won't be long.
I'll be right back!
Alrighty!
Okay...
Okie dokie!
Sorry about that!
Alright, let's investigate!
We got some contact...
Lenses!
He's got...
No!
He plays Sudoku!
Boring hobby!
So true!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
What is this?
Foundation?
Makeup?
Fussy?
Is that the...
Nail gloss?
Waterproof eyeliner?
Foundation?
Lots of...
A lot of foundation.
Who needs that much makeup?
Mito favorite gacha game?
Blue Archive!
Except...
I
don't...
I don't...
Okay...
Ugh...
Right now they're having...
Blue Archive...
The festival...
The fest...
In Blue Archive...
And...
Oh...
It's...
It's going really bad for me...
And I already...
I already had to...
I already had bad luck on the last banner...
With Seiya...
If you play...
I was able to still get Seiya and Schoolgirl Asana...
But this banner...
Oh...
It's...
It's really...
It's really bad...
Oh...
I have...
Save for...
I can't...
I have nothing left...
I...
I needed...
Swimsuit Hanako...
I have not had her this entire time...
And I really...
I was like...
I need her...
And...
I'm at...
I think it was like...
225...
Pulls...
And I have not pulled anybody...
No Rio...
No Hanako...
I haven't gotten anyone...
No Nehru...
Yeah...
It's really...
Really bad...
And I...
I did spend money...
And I still did...
I love...
I mean...
With 225...
I can spark...
But...
I...
I wanted both of them...
And at this point...
I'm not gonna get...
I'm not gonna get either of them...
Or I'm gonna get only one of them...
I guess...
Uh...
And it makes me so sad...
Because...
I love Blue Archive...
So much...
But my gacha luck...
Has been so bad...
I'm like...
What?
Do you want me to go to...
Umamusume?
Huh?
I will go to...
Umamusume...
Uh...
The game hates me...
And this was...
This all happened today...
So I was really bummed out...
About it actually...
It really kind of...
It's so sad...
Isn't it kind of pathetic...
For me to be like...
My gacha pulls...
Ruined my day...
But when you spend money...
And you...
Pull so much...
And you still don't get what you want...
It's like...
Oh...
It's so bad...
It's a hundred percent...
First world...
World problems...
A hundred percent...
You love blue archive...
But it isn't loving you back...
It's so one-sided...
I know...
I wish it would stop being so tsundere for me...
Gacha funds...
Thank you...
Thank you so much...
I asked you for gacha luck...
During horse game...
And I managed to pull saber...
And her light cone...
In Hongkai star whale...
So I'm passing my residual luck...
I don't think I have any gemmies left...
To do another pull...
Unless I spend money...
Which I already spent...
A lot of money...
Not...
Over a hundred dollars...
But...
Still enough money...
I had in the bottom...
One percent luck...
In ZZZZ...
Before I quit...
A new banner...
Dropped a new...
And people are suffering...
I heard about that...
Spending money...
To tell you...
It's okay to be sad...
About bad luck...
After spending money...
Me...
Thank you...
It's rough out there...
Awesome blue...
Thank you...
Awesome suit Hanako fights...
I am suffering...
I do gotta play more...
UMA though...
I'm not very good...
About playing games...
On my PC...
You know...
Or especially...
Gacha games...
On my PC...
I'm not used to it...
Cause I never did like...
Emulators...
Or anything like that...
I'm too stupid...
I understand...
I've had days like those...
Especially when money is spent...
Yeah...
Do you guys understand...
My pain...
Additional gacha fuzz...
To go with the luck...
No...
Thank you...
I hit hard penny...
Three times in a row...
On FGO...
Before I quit...
The pain is real...
Yeah...
Oh...
It hurts...
Gacha hurts...
I put...
I got two kitas...
And ten pulls...
That's quite a scarf collection...
Blue...
Striped...
Checkered...
One for every occasion...
Hmm...
I like the striped one...
Whoa...
Blue...
Clues...
Blue's clues...
Oh...
I'm gonna snoop on your computer now...
He's on Mootube...
Ten best...
Oh...
I thought it was gonna...
Oh my gosh...
I thought it...
I almost thought it said...
Ten best cheats...
For chess...
King...
Best...
Chest...
No...
Best...
Chess...
King...
Moments...
He hasn't uploaded it yet...
Queen...
How is my army hero doing today?
I can't wait any longer.
You said you'll send me the photos.
Patience, my queen.
First, you'll need to give me my present.
Hope they release some more Koharu merch for you to make up for the gacha pin.
I hope not!
So, you know what's kind of great?
Chyna loves Koharu.
So they always release really good merch of her.
I feel like he's getting catfished.
Maybe.
Then you can request any photo...
Any photo of me?
What?
And solitaire!
Don't fund my bad luck, you guys.
Your money is going to nothing.
Chyna loves who?
Koharu!
My- my best girl in Blue Archive.
Only Chyna Blue Archive releases goods of her.
Your money is wasted because I have too bad of luck and I never pull it!
No!
Are in this chat.
Nothing fun!
Don't you feel bad snooping around on people's laptops?
Looking at their... personal information?
They never wanted anyone to see- Oh my gosh, Freddy has sense.
That's the whole point of being a detective!
I guess that makes sense too.
Not a fund.
Thank you, welcome back, Master Paladin!
Here's number one!
Okay...
Oh, what's this?
Oh...
The scarf is yellow.
Frog!
Our nose...
Morning routine secrets.
Suggestive look unnerving.
Does he take photos of himself with him wherever he goes?
Wow!
That's a big trophy!
He must be super good at chess.
Wouldn't be surprised if he's cheating somehow.
The...
The vibrator up his butt!
Jeez!
You guys ever hear about that?
You...
Do you...
Do you know what I'm talking about?
There was a guy...
Who got accused.
He was like a master chess player.
He got accused of cheating.
And it's because they suspect he...
Had something up his...
His...
His butt!
That was vibrating to tell him...
What was to do?
You...
Wow!
I'd rather spend this on your...
And...
No!
No...
Thank you so much for the pink though.
I got a peeker sticker of vodka from Uma for my car today, so please enjoy gacha funds.
I picked vodka as my fave because of her name, but I genuinely love her now.
That's wholesome.
Thank you.
No, don't...
Good luck with rolling Kita.
I give you my luck, even though I don't have much at all.
I did hear about the chest butt guy.
I don't think it was confirmed, just allegations.
But I think it's strong allegations.
Everybody, look at all this lotion.
Wait, there's actually...
Wait, what's this?
What is this?
Looks like a tiny recording device.
Do you think someone is listening in on Arnaud?
Arnaud.
So creepy.
Creepy.
Maybe.
Creepy added to the clues.
I see.
What do you have to say?
If you were a ghost, what kind of ghost would you be?
Oh, me.
Me, me, me, me.
Pick me, pick me.
I would be a vengeful ghost because that's what I am.
Would be fun to be some sort of horrible, vengeful ghost.
There are some people that deserve to be haunted.
I hope you don't mean me.
Tell the gacha you will delete it.
If you don't pull what you want, trust me, it works.
I should have done that.
I feel the desire meter.
I couldn't hold back, you know?
And so it knew that I wanted...
It knew that I wanted her very strongly.
We're causing you to bring up your gacha page.
No, it's okay.
I love talking about it.
Damn.
Please forgive me.
Also, please bless my polls for Hoshino.
I bless...
Your polls!
I bless if everybody is polling for something.
Either in Honkai or Umao or Blue Archive.
I bless.
Soon, we will meet.
For now, I have your scent.
Your queen.
Skate Geek.
Thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
My lucky charm.
What's the scent?
What is it?
Oh.
Scratch marks.
Old.
I wonder what this lucky charm is.
There's a lot of lotion, you guys.
I was just kidding about...
But there's just half...
There's a lot of lotion.
You know, you almost seem happy about the vandalism happening.
We're even knocking it over.
I'm here to help.
Alright, let's talk to Arnaud.
It feels so...
Invasive.
Invasive?
What if they come back...
And attack me?
Did they steal anything?
Oh...
I...
I don't know.
You haven't checked?
You seem to take yourself very seriously.
But of course...
Treat yourself how you want others to treat you.
How else do you think I take all this prize money on?
Confidence is everything.
And the clear skin.
Don't read my name wrong.
Tom!
Thank you for the super chat.
I just got Kita-san black after your blessing.
Thanks, Minto.
Happy!
Ah, it works every time.
This is a recording device we found in your tent.
Phew!
This is a tent?
What?
What would someone do with recordings of me?
Is this a stalker?
Maybe they want to...
Blackmail you?
Oh!
Alright, let's see what we got here.
Vandalism!
Um...
Someone decided to...
Maybe...
Blackmail the...
The...
The creepy...
The creepy creepy...
Of creepy...
Wait, what?
Huh?
The sniffing check is real!
Black... They wanted to...
Steal the creepy, creepy...
No, we definitely have all the pieces.
It's 14 out of 14.
But... Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Of...
Arno...
They wanted to...
Okay,
thank you so much for the dead gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
What is... What are our clues for the...
Like...
Wait, what was the creepy...
There was something creepy.
What was creepy?
Was it this?
Was this the creepy?
No, this is Lucky.
What was creepy?
Creepy?
What?
Oh, creepy was the listening device.
Well, they...
Don't wanna...
They...
I don't think they were going to steal the listening device because...
It was right there in the middle of the floor.
Does the lotion count?
Do you think it was the...
Because there's two adjectives here?
Is it the yellow...
What it...
The...
No...
It wasn't checkered or anything.
Or maybe the lucky yellow scarf.
Because the scarf...
I noticed the...
The yellow scarf was the only one not there.
The goal wasn't to vandalize, but to steal Arno's lucky scarf.
Yeah, yeah.
I wondered what pushed the person to these legs.
Maybe that's what the scent was.
And then the deviant.
Lank...
Arno is getting...
Something via chat messages by...
Lanks.
Creepy.
Yeah, he was wearing the yellow scarf...
In the picture.
But it wasn't over here.
I did notice that earlier.
Look, it's even...
It's supposed...
I guess it was supposed to be...
Oh, actually no, I can't tell.
Okay, what?
When in doubt, creepy.
Creepy...
Stalker.
Wait.
It's getting...
Blackmailed via chat messages.
Almost everything's wrong.
It's not a creepy stalker?
It said it's a lucky stalker.
Maybe...
Maybe it's Katya.
No?
Because she's the assistant, but clearly not.
Lucky stalker.
Locker.
Ooh la la.
Um...
Bribed.
With...
Personal...
Photos?
Okay, so someone's getting bribed.
How do we know this though?
I'm just guessing, but how do we know this?
I'm trying to think of where the information is coming from.
Because we got all the...
The...
Deductions, but...
Who am I to say...
That it's any of these...
Let's go, Mita!
Thank you!
Lucky stalker.
Driven to steal lucky scarves.
To help with gacha pulls.
It was on the computer.
The queen.
Oh, that's right!
They were like, how's...
How's my army hero?
So it's Matilda.
I can't wait any longer.
You said you'll send me the photos!
Okay.
So it's Matilda.
You little freak, Matilda!
Matilda was getting bribed?
I wondered what the present was that they were talking about.
Alright.
It was time to deduce who was behind the theft.
The thief!
Blank stole Arnod's scarf because he, she, is his...
Stalker.
Oh.
Maybe it's...
Maybe it's Matilda.
Because she is his queen!
It was Matilda who was behind this.
Fortune!
This was getting quite scandalous.
Every year, Matilda Eisenman and her son Toby go on vacation to Sunny Lake.
What is this Conan music?
This year, Matilda's wildest dreams are coming true.
Arnaud Benoit, a famous chess streamer, is staying at the campsite.
Who Matilda happens to be a huge fan of.
She started chatting with him online.
And was asked to strike a deal in return for...
Wait, it was actually him?
Oh?
That's crazy.
Arnaud asked her to stay away from him for discretion, but Matilda grew impatient.
In her desperate state, she broke into the VIP tent and stole Arnaud's lucky scar.
That makes sense, she wasn't there at the ghost store.
Uh, Mr. Duck Detective.
You've been silently staring into the distance for a while now.
No, I'm just...
Figuring out the case.
He's such a good detective.
Tell me, tell me!
Not yet.
There are still a lot of unknowns.
I'd rather not make my deductions public before I got the whole picture.
But, but I'm your assistant, and then...
We need to find more information on Matilda Eisenman.
Oh, okay.
He doesn't trust.
He doesn't believe.
He doesn't...
Freddy, shh, Freddy, shh.
Trust in the system.
I think we've got everything in here.
Yep, okay.
We're good to leave.
Oh, I'm stuck.
There we go.
Wait.
Where are you going?
You said you would help me.
Um, and that's what I'll do.
Later.
After I sorted out some other things.
Useless.
Oh my gosh.
Rude.
I'd rather be useless than rude.
Wait, what?
We need to find a way to enter Matilda's room.
What did that say about duck divorces?
Sounds fun!
What did that say about duck divorces now?
Oh.
Oh, that scared me too.
Mr. Jack detective.
Back when you were with the police.
Uh, your precinct.
Did they think you were cool?
Um, I only really spoke to my partner.
Oh.
I see.
Oh, whoops.
Didn't mean to close out a bit.
So, this, uh, partner of yours from the precinct.
Do you like them more than me?
No.
I don't even know you're the partner.
I don't even know.
They mate for life except when they get divorced.
That's what it said.
Oh.
I mean, he was a bit boring.
Heh.
You're definitely not gonna have a boring moment with me.
So true, Freddy.
Sorry, I wanted to see if there's anything over here, but there seems to be not.
So let's get into Matilda's house.
Breaking and entering.
This is unit number two.
How do we get the key?
Didn't we see Matilda's bag somewhere?
The BL root.
Wait, what'd you say?
This is unit number two.
We saw a key where?
How do we get the key?
Didn't we see Matilda's bag somewhere?
Oh yeah, it was on the, it was on the, the lake.
The stars are truly beautiful out here, aren't they?
Ah, the sky is beautiful.
It's a bug?
Yeah, to listen in on people.
Ooh, looks like a newer model as well.
How would you know that?
Theodore?
Is the moon a star?
You're the only star in my heart.
Does that answer your question?
Does that answer some distress in your aura?
That's just you, Amelia.
I'm fine.
Are you, though?
What is Toby Eisenman like?
I try my best for him to have fun here, but...
I don't think he's having a good time.
He wants to play his little, his uh, Nintendo's.
Do you have any information on Theodore Stumperton?
Poor soul is going through some...
He's right there!
I should pick up some gemstones for him, to improve his karma!
Oh my God!
Oh, that guy!
He's just really going through it!
Man, his karma is shot!
Damn, that guy!
Damn, Amelia!
Have some tact!
We found this in the VIP tent.
Do you have an explanation?
Oh, what?
I've never seen that before.
I don't even know what it is!
Uh, that's very suspicious, Amelia.
Extremely suspicious response now.
So...
You stopped messaging your ex, right?
Why do you care?
I...
I caved after three days.
Thank you!
After three days!
Maybe I could, uh, introduce you to some of Katya's friends?
It's too early.
It's been a year!
Nine months.
Uh...
The baby is born.
Think about it.
The baby...
The divorced baby is born.
You know what?
I just realized...
I was like, Freddy sounds so familiar to me.
And it finally hit me on the head, just now.
Freddy sounds like an old co-worker that I had.
Except...
Like...
If Freddy was a...
Was a lady.
And...
But she sounds exact...
She sounds exactly like Freddy.
Like when I...
When I was an office ghost.
Okay.
Her bag was on the beach, I remember.
Oh my gosh.
Now I can't unhear it.
Kind of like...
I heard it immediately when...
He was like...
When Freddy was like...
Maybe I should introduce you to some of Katya's friends.
That's...
Uh oh.
Why do I have to stay?
There are no buses or taxis out here at night.
Please.
Get yourself together.
And tomorrow...
We'll leave.
Okay?
Fine.
Just so you're aware...
I'll probably gain a wrinkle from all this stress.
What the heck?
Who's...
Who's drawing witchcraft in the sand?
How mysterious.
That seems like a case for...
The investigator!
How long have you been holding that one back?
Basically since we arrived.
15 months of for Ricky!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Pedro!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, we've seen this circle before though.
I fear...
What's that?
Cloth remains burnt.
Wasn't Theodore wearing a flannel?
Was that...
A stick with sand?
Ash.
You guys, I still think of that one moment in the Pokemon movie.
Where...
What was it, Pokemon 2000?
Where they say...
That the world will turn to ash.
But they mean it in a...
Where they...
They...
Instead of saying the world will turn to...
Like, get burnt up.
They're like...
They mean it literally...
Where they're like, everyone's gonna look at that guy.
I literally...
I think about that all the time.
Not like burn.
Like, literally they will turn to ash Ketchum.
Yes!
They're like...
They're so upset.
I mean, it's like an old, old prophecy.
They're like, oh my gosh.
If this happens, the world will turn to ash.
They just meant the world's gonna look at this 10 year old.
Like...
What even is this?
It's so...
It's such a good pun though.
It's...
It's so good.
The localization team cooked with that, honestly.
They cooked with that.
I can't tell...
Okay, these are orange.
I think these are gray.
Okay.
Normally, I'd take a bath to distress.
Okay, my 2,000 was so peak though.
Yeah!
I don't have to go back into that cursed tent.
That cursed tent.
I can't do with that.
I don't know what Arno is complaining about.
He gained 10,000 followers while we were here.
What?
That's insane!
Because of here?
Or...
Guys, I'm close to 400k.
No.
Wait.
Uh...
I'm close to 400,000 subscribers.
So, um...
Help...
Help a ghost out.
Q.
Camp!
Wait...
L...
Wait!
I remember where we saw the symbol!
I think it was...
On the lock for the...
I think it was here.
Hold on.
I wanna double check.
Over here?
I think it was...
Here.
Oh!
It was that!
It was that.
It was this.
Kinda similar.
Daima!
Thank you so much for the brain!
Hello, hello!
Thank you!
All the wisps gather to create 15k accounts.
I want to get them.
To the spooky subscriber number.
Let's see.
Hey!
I can't see them, dude!
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Endorgo!
Thank you so much for the vibe!
I'm gifted!
Ducky!
Thank you for the gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Oh!
It tells me.
Kill!
Oh!
Nevermind.
It can't be kill.
How am I supposed to figure this out?
Wait.
I'm trying to think.
What other...
King!
It must be King!
She's thinking of her king!
It's Quop!
Thank you so much!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship!
I hope I said your name right.
Shopkeeper!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
I got an achievement, but I didn't see what it was.
My bad.
Okay.
Oh.
Search the bag.
We got her unit key.
Steal that.
Cod liver oil for kids!
How to raise a warrior.
A guide for the military mom.
We got...
We got that.
The scarf?
Lucky scarf.
Stolen goods!
What do I see here?
A key!
It must open one of the accommodations here.
Nice.
We're just gonna steal that and not give back the scarf, I guess.
We're just, uh...
You know, he'll find it on his own if he...
Really wants it that bad.
When are we gonna see a ghost?
The neatly kept cabin promised the ordinary.
But I knew there was dirt amongst this cleanliness.
Ooh.
There's always dirt.
My dad used to take me fishing.
Catching carp was the only way he knew how to bond with me.
Carp!
Kitties!
Thank you so much for the fun.
Thank you!
I'm seeing one right now.
A dirt?
Are you?
Why does this card game need over 100 cards?
At least 100 cards!
This was designed to drain parents out of their money.
And more to see.
That's just the base set!
The Omega Booster Packs is where the real fun starts!
Wow.
Are Pokemon cards still getting scalped up the wazoo?
At the moment?
Are they still...
Yeah, they are!
Gosh.
That...
The, uh...
What's it called?
Um...
What is this thing floating right there?
See that?
Oh!
There we go.
Oh my god!
There's a camera in this plushie!
That's freaky.
Oh, it's...
And it's Toby's!
I don't know what's up recently.
I feel like...
The co...
The quote-unquote collect...
Not collector community, but like...
There's...
People are going crazy with collecting right now, you know?
Feels like Beanie Babies all over again, but worse.
Toby, old.
There is a hidden camera in this plushie?
That's freaky!
What a shame to ruin such a cute Goldilocks!
I should take this with me.
We're just stealing the plushie.
What is this?
Oh, I think it's like a little piece of the...
You guys...
Did you guys see it?
It was like a...
I don't...
I don't know.
It was weird.
Anyway.
Inga!
Ah...
Photo...
Military...
Can't believe you had a thing with that guy.
Eh...
It was a bit of a crazy time.
He wasn't the only one.
You gifted 30 subs!
Confidential...
Information on Project L03...
Is strictly confidential...
And will be...
Handed out in person...
Kitchen etiquette reminder...
Unread...
Hello?
Open the room.
Confidential secrets...
Is this L-L-L, maybe?
Maybe, yeah.
Strictly confidential, huh?
Curious.
Digital Canary.
You gifted 20 memberships.
Thank you so much.
You didn't have to do that, but thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I think we've explored everything in here.
Which was pretty crazy.
Jessie!
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Wait.
It's not showing...
It's completed.
Maybe it is.
I don't know.
What do you make of this plush?
I clicked the wrong thing, my bad.
This one.
Have you seen this plushie before?
Sammy, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Welcome!
I personally don't know much about it, but...
It's from this thing the kids are into nowadays, isn't it?
This thing!
Hmm...
Rest in glitch ways, thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where are they anyway?
Toby and, uh...
And his mom.
Okay.
Do you know what this is?
What can you tell me about this plushie?
Ew!
Take that smelly old thing away from me!
Poor guy.
Can you tell me anything about this plush toy?
Do you think it's cute?
Uh...
Why are you asking me this?
Well...
Maybe a certain someone will give you a certain present at some point.
Please...
Don't buy me more things.
Sh...
Does she like him?
Like...
Is this a...
Is this a successful relationship?
Phoebe!
Thank you for the rain!
I thought I'd be asking you to send some chills and frights my way because my AC broke yesterday, but they just fixed it in time for stream!
Yeah, I'm so happy for you.
Oh my gosh.
My AC broke not so long ago, actually.
Luckily, they fixed it pretty quickly, but...
I know your struggle.
Phoebe!
Oh, here they are.
There's a strange smell coming from that hut.
Thank you, Siftu.
Thank you so much for that gift, though.
Take up and ya-nya and thank you for the gift, though!
What do you know about this stuffed toy?
Toby takes it with him wherever he goes.
I feel he is way too old for plush toys, but...
I guess I can forbid him everything.
You can't be too old for plush toys.
It's not easy, you're a single parent.
What do you mean, too old for plush toys?
What's your favorite Magicorn?
This will say a lot about you, Mr. Dat Detective!
You're a favorite.
Oh, I think I am, um...
Uh...
I think I like...
Mouch.
I like...
What a name.
Mouch?
That's a very basic one.
I'll introduce you to some more Magicorn when we're back home.
They're laughing at me.
I say Mouch and they're laughing at me.
I guess you're not allowed to like a basic Poke...
I mean, a...
Magicorn anymore.
Do you know anything about this plushie?
I take cold, he walks with me everywhere.
But yesterday, she was gone.
Why?
I couldn't find her at all.
Interesting.
And then, this morning, she was in front of our room.
What is this accent?
You can burr her if you want, but don't lose her.
I can burr her?
Is that what you just said?
I can what her?
Bury her?
Bury her if you want.
There's a suspicious smell coming from this...
The waft of incense and fresh linen were the first things to hit my nose.
The decor of the hut screamed of spiritual freedom.
But on closer inspection, this was a temple to unfettered materialism.
She doesn't...
She's...
She is all, like, supposed to be spiritual and, like...
Hippie dippie, but...
She's the exact...
Her personality is the exact opposite.
Oh my goodness, there's so many clothes in here.
Oh, thank God, they're fake cows.
Makes it less romantic, don't you think?
What does that sound?
Oh, it's the coffee pot.
What do we got in here?
A recipe?
Main chakras.
Courage.
That's that symbol!
Love.
It's a squiggle.
Health is key.
And the joy.
Modifiers.
Lose.
Gain.
Last step.
Burn something of the person...
You're trying...
You want...
You...
Something...
To affect.
This can be a part of their body...
Or their possessions.
Oh!
The...
The shirt!
People will do anything...
Including questionable rituals...
To avoid doing any work themselves.
I don't know about that.
This...
Does look like a lot of work.
So he wanted...
What was it?
Courage?
But...
Perhaps?
But it looked a little different than that symbol.
All of these clothes still have the tags on.
Oh, those are clothes!
I thought they were books!
I have a ton of packages to send back.
I have a feeling that will never happen.
I thought they were books!
Wait, they're all clothes!
What is going on in here?
What is happening?
Was it...
Oh!
Let's snoop on the laptop, baby!
The symbol was indeed the same?
Was it?
I thought it had like a cross through it.
Final notice.
Pending electric bill.
Overdue bills.
Irresponsible?
Or broke?
I don't know.
Television license.
Wow!
Check out our fashion sale!
Reminder.
Unpaid...
Unpaid lease!
We have...
We have funny gifts.
We have horoscope.
We have coupons!
We have bills.
Zalandodo.shop.
Four buns is crazy.
We would get kicked out in there by then.
Shopping cart.
Oh, this is the cart.
This is not...
We're not window shopping here.
23 items in the cart!
Have you found something to bring?
I'll bring one of my old shirts.
Yeah, you could also afford to bring one of your old shirts.
I don't think I've ever had 23 things in a cart before.
That's just like...
That's insane.
This...
Gives me a lot of anxiety.
Wow, me too.
Me too!
I think I've got...
Everything in here.
Yeah.
Seems to be the case.
I have on Baie.
Not even in the grocery store?
Okay, but that's different.
Even steam sale.
I don't think I've done that many.
Okay, patterns in the sand.
Okay, so...
Amelia helped...
Theodore perform a...
A courage...
Wait.
Perform a ritual...
To make...
Or wait.
Hold on.
Theodore...
Gain...
Courage.
Oh!
I was right!
Theodore was trying to summon courage?
I wondered what for?
Machine for Games!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
It was time I got back into snooping around Matilda's room.
Nice.
Oh, back to Matilda's room.
Okay.
The cabin.
Lank is being...
Watched.
To try and gain access to...
To secrets.
Secrets.
To...
To her military secrets!
Matilda's being watched!
Military secrets are at stake?
I had to be careful not to stir the pot too soon.
The less people knew, the better.
Woo!
This is how it must have went down.
Uh oh.
Oh.
Matilda Eisenman has brought sensitive military information with her to the campsite.
Someone at the campsite seems to be after this intel.
And decided to spy on her by hiding a camera inside her son's plushie.
Also, it seems that Theodore Stumperton seeked out Emilia Dinkle's help.
But for courage for what?
To perform a ritual that would grant him courage.
Wow.
It was time that I found out who this person was that was after the military secrets.
Military secrets.
This person.
This is getting pretty serious.
Yura yura.
Kawaii.
Oh!
In order to find out who is spying on the eyes and loves.
Yura yura.
We need to ask for access to all accommodations on this premise.
What?
You see, it's really important that...
Yes.
Oh!
Freddie!
Thank you for coming, everyone.
Is he a distraction?
What?
What are you...
The duck detective and I have made some serious deductions.
Wait, he's taken all...
And one of you is in serious trouble.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Freddie...
Because this someone is spying on the Eisenmans!
Why are you giving that away?
They're gonna leave.
All right, Frederson.
This is enough.
He's blowing our case.
The window!
Huh?
How...
How is this possible?
All the lamps have been stolen by vandals ages ago!
Oh...
Yeah, he's stealing the beans!
There, it must be the ghost!
Hold on!
Where did my Toby go?
Uh-oh.
He was just here a second ago!
I don't think he was.
Do you see the fog rolling in?
That means Patient 12 is coming out, looking for her son.
Oh!
Can we stop with this ghost thing just for a moment?
The music is so nice.
Father will come and save you, little Toby!
Not the mood.
I'm definitely not getting any sleep tonight.
Spooky...
This was all getting far too dramatic.
Freddie!
To find out what was going on with these military secrets.
Freddie, I'm about to slap you!
I was also very curious to find a way into the abandoned sanatorium.
I should probably also find out where Toby disappeared to.
I wondered if that odd-looking shed by the toilets had anything to do with it.
This is so much fun, isn't it?
I bet this is much better than doing your detective work alone.
Don't talk to me.
Yeah, actually...
You really stepped over the line back there.
You tell him!
Oh!
Did I?
Whatever.
Oh, Freddie, you can't just...
You have to...
If you...
If you show all your cards before...
Before you have a conclusion, they're just gonna...
They're gonna hide the evidence!
He's so...
He's too silly!
Oh my gosh...
Whoa...
Scary...
Can't we just...
Brick in?
No, why not?
A detective uses their brain...
Not their brawn.
Hear me out.
Murder...
Yeah...
He uses his brain, not his brawn.
This is spooky, isn't it?
Yeah...
Are you easily spooked?
No...
Do you like horror movies?
Yes...
Can I just do my work, please?
Oh, uh, of course.
The knife is still here.
Um...
He mentioned this shed, but...
That is the shed he's talking about, right?
Why don't you go to the...
He said...
The shed!
Oh!
Oh no!
Clumsy duck!
Oh!
I've come to confess my crimes.
I love mint.
Death penalty!
This box wasn't here before!
What?
If it has something to do with Toby's disappearance?
Oh, my poor boy!
What if he's in danger?
What if he got kidnapped?
You know?
I should've put a GPS tracker on Toby!
People made fun of me!
But this just shows that people are in denial!
At least he has his dog tag on him.
His dog tag...
It's like a...
It's like a literal collar.
Whoa!
Triple geese.
Mobile game.
Magicorn Go!
Oh!
It's Magicorn Go!
Magicorn Go!
Magicorn Go to the polls!
Natural bait.
A key to...
Number three.
I'm missing something.
Missing one more thing.
It's bait.
Oh!
I love mint too!
Don't tell anyone, okay?
Hey!
Where are these confessions coming from?
Someone must've left in a hurry and forgot the box.
A key!
Let's find out what this unlocks.
Exciting!
I wasn't talking to you!
I mean, there's only one tent that we haven't gone into.
You fools!
We are lament-o!
Oh, Theodore was staying at this one.
Kano wants to go home because of every single tiny thing!
He's being way too dramatic!
Hmph.
How uncharacteristic.
Your sarcasm isn't helping.
I don't think he's being that dramatic.
His tent got broken into and his stuff was stolen.
I think, um, he's pretty valid, actually.
No, I am Sparta.
I mean, I love mint.
I love mint though!
Please tell everyone!
Yippee!
I'm gonna jump off the cliff!
Oh no!
We can't let the ghost keep the child!
We need to fight it!
Why not?
This wasn't much of a blessing in disguise after all!
Don't fight it!
Let the ghost take the child!
No, mint!
Heehee!
I don't think we can do this one yet, right?
His building looks what the door is locked.
Oh, that's right.
What is this?
Yeah, it won't even let us touch, like, uh...
Won't even let me click it.
Oh no!
The pressure!
I must confess that!
That what?
Is he in the hot tub?
No.
I would be in.
This is a perfect time for a hot tub.
Yeah, the lock uses the symbols.
Exactly.
I feel like we should be able to...
Unlock it now, but I guess not.
Okay, he's not in here either.
You wanted to say something?
Are you still mad at me?
Ooh.
Yes.
What can I do to make it up to you?
Ooh.
Uh, do you want ice cream?
I could hit you a magic horn.
Just like the one for Katya.
Just be quiet.
Please.
Oh, speaking like, uh...
There was the knitted...
Hold on, in here.
I saw...
This?
Um...
There was...
I don't remember what convention it was.
But, um...
Ashton.
Ashton Martin.
Another VTuber.
She...
Saw someone that was selling crocheted Sanrio characters.
And she got me...
Hanamaru!
I was so happy.
What is the deal with this ghost affair?
Do you believe in ghosts, detective?
Yes.
I've had some strange things happen to me.
My dirty dishes on my desk would just...
Disappear.
Was this when you were still living with Anna?
Oh.
Um...
Yes.
Why?
Oh...
Nothing.
Anyway.
Whatever is happening here...
Is definitely not caused by some ghost.
Sounds like denial to me.
Not Anna picking up his dishes.
Radix, thank you!
Thank you so much for 15 months.
I think Minto is pretty okay, I guess.
I too love Minto and I accept my death penalty.
What is...
What is all this?
You know what I say to this?
That's what I say.
A load of honkin' baloney.
Good morning, Meebo.
Good morning, Glitcherman.
Lost my train of thought.
What was I saying?
Maybe I'll remember later.
Yeah, you should get that looked at.
Yes.
Do
you have any tips on how to date cute ghost maids?
The dank caravan gave off a troubled energy.
Just what did I walked into here?
I don't know.
Whoa, it's red.
Oh, my eyes!
It's like a beat in here.
Whoa!
Oh!
It's dank.
A dank energy.
Drive them with merch.
No!
Wear a headband.
Close.
Getting warmer.
Oh, yeah.
Knock it all over!
Wait, can I step in the bear trap?
Oh, it's really sad that I can't knock all of these over.
I'm not gonna lie.
Some glasses.
Reading glasses.
Live, laugh, love!
L, L, L!
Tacky.
Courage.
Health.
Love.
Joy!
It was joy!
Main chakras.
This one is better.
The last few months, I've been thinking.
And I believe you deserve to know this.
I'm hoping this will bring some peace to my mind.
What did he do?
Guilt.
I know this will seem sudden, but...
Interesting.
This note looks strange.
I should ask people what they make of this.
Yes.
And the clue.
The music in here is so spooky.
Oops.
One thing is for sure.
In here, it's impossible to die of starvation.
Unless...
You can't open your mouth.
What do we got here?
Okay, this is a lot.
School club enrollment.
Eisenman Toby.
He did not make it into wrestling.
But that's connected to...
A picture of Toby.
Just connected to a...
Brezel.
Country.
East Canton.
There he is!
On a boat!
Staring at the glaciers.
Sunny lakeside luxurious camping.
Another country.
West Canton.
Local kid wins magicorn tournament.
This guy is obsessed...
With Toby!
Timestamps?
Sunny lake.
Current location.
School.
Eisenman Toby.
Wait.
Purchases magicorn cards.
Cold...
Deluxe plushie.
Why do we have a school ID?
And then...
The...
The military photo from the mom.
This is all very suspicious.
Sorry, I have a stretcher.
Um...
I don't like this.
Yeah.
That's...
That's weird.
Is...
Is his sign...
Is there a capybara?
No!
There wasn't capybara in the middle...
Wait.
You think?
But wouldn't she know?
Wouldn't she recognize her...
You know?
I don't think that's a capybara.
I don't know what the heck that is.
That is Matilda, the mom.
I don't know who the heck that...
But those glasses...
Those are the same...
Are those not the same reading glasses?
The same blue ones in the suitcase?
Here, here.
There.
These.
Hmm...
Keep that in mind.
So now we ask everybody about...
Uh... something.
Oh, this...
Can you tell me anything about these notes?
The notes...
So much of it is crossed out.
Mary!
It doesn't scream of a very confident rider.
Thank you!
For the breakdown!
For Annie!
For your Annie Red!
Congratulations on your four year!
Thank you for the gifted!
Hey, kiss!
Bring it back, thank you!
Ducky, thank you!
Congrats, congrats!
Oh, I'm so old!
Yeah!
It's not like this year is my fifth year anniversary or anything.
You're so old!
Yeah!
But you're Boomer!
I'm Boomer!
Get it?
Murphy, thank you!
Paperbacks, thank you!
Teacup, nyan-nyan, thank you!
Ragpubrabu, thank you!
Cici, thank you!
Duargo, thank you!
Chase, thank you!
Thank you guys, all for the gifted.
Alright, let's ask some more people about this...
Sussy note.
Do you notice anything about this...
Notebook?
I've never seen it.
Wait, who says this?
Are you...
Spying on people?
I'm a detective.
Snooping is my job.
Uh...
And now we leave.
Crocodiles make the most loyal friends.
Ah!
Hey, Mom!
What is this?
What do you make of these notes?
It will bring peace to my mind?
Who writes like this?
Is this some serial killer's diary?
You've been active for like two years?
Yeah, I guess that's true.
But I did start...
Fi...
Almost.
Five years ago.
Actually, wait...
When was my debut?
Wait a second.
Did I put it in my calendar?
Wait...
Uh...
One moment.
Uh-oh.
Did I...
Miss it?
What?
I just realized it's July.
Wait...
The 24th!
Next week!
Five...
Year anniversary.
Can you guys tell?
I'm so...
I'm so prepared!
No...
Wow!
Oh my god!
We let you know if you missed it.
Happy almost anniversary!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Hi!
Last year, you made such a big deal of her one four-year.
Oopsie.
Okay, well...
That's not what we're worried about right now.
Right now, we've got a case to solve.
Where is...
Not Toby.
That other guy.
He doesn't even care about the note.
Where is that guy?
He's not out here, is he?
Okay...
I didn't even see him.
Hiding around here.
Mr. Capybara!
Was his name Theodore?
Are you in here?
Are you...
Wait!
Why is this unlocked now?
This toilet is making...
Sounds like it's...
No, remember it!
It was...
It was not...
Oh, here we go!
We can do this now.
Uh...
Shoot.
It's live, laugh, love.
I think it's this one, then...
Squiggle...
Then...
No?
Was that not it?
Yeah, it was all taped up before.
Yeah.
Uh...
Where's the book?
Of symbols.
Book of symbols!
Where are you?
Oh, here we go.
Love!
Live, laugh, love.
So squiggle is...
So it'll be joy...
Joy...
Health, love.
Right?
What was joy again?
Wait...
Oh, shoot.
This one...
And then...
This one.
Eh?
Wait, did I...
Oh, wait.
Live, health, laugh is joy.
There we go.
I'm such a...
I'm a fake wine mommy.
Ah, I did it!
Alright.
Let's see what's inside this strange building.
Yay!
We still haven't found Theodore, though.
Toby's whereabouts.
Toby is...
In...
The...
Lake.
Okay, hold on.
We're not there yet.
Oop, my bad.
Yeah!
The moldy stench invaded my nostrils.
And made me dread what was to come.
But there was no going back now.
Thank you!
What an adventure this is, right, Mr. Duck Detective?
I...
Uh...
Eugene...
I...
Uh...
About before...
Mm-hmm, huh.
I shouldn't have meddled...
With your detective face.
Come back on!
Uh, uh...
Debbie, thank you so much for the courage.
Thank you, we're solving a...
Not a murder mystery today.
Well, you better step up then.
Y-yes!
I-I will!
I hope you had fun at the hospital.
I'll be the best sidekick ever from now on.
All right, we should move on.
Some kid just got kidnapped.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the brave of me.
Fargo, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you so much.
So many people, thank you.
Superliminal, thank you, chain, thank you.
Spankin' arm, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, sir.
Come back.
Come back, naplings.
Okay, here.
Actually, this is good.
This is good for a summary, right?
So...
Since people are here.
We are duck detective.
And we are doing deductions.
And this is our assistant, Freddy.
He's a little eccentric.
But he's actually more normal than duck detective, I think.
And we went to this...
To this campsite.
Because Freddy likes...
Going to horror locations.
And he also wanted to spend time with his girlfriend.
And while we were here...
There is...
Oops.
There's a cast.
We got Emilia.
She...
Is...
The manager of the...
Of the...
The campgrounds.
Is...
Matilda.
And her...
Son...
Toby.
Katya.
Is...
Freddy's girlfriend.
And Katya.
Is the manager of this...
Bunny.
Who is a chess...
Fluencer.
And...
Then Theodore.
Who is just a capybara.
And we found out that...
Matilda's in the army.
And someone is spying on her...
For military secrets.
And also...
Matilda's son just got kidnapped...
By a ghost maybe.
And...
Did I cover everything?
Oh, and...
Arno...
And Matilda...
Were having like a king and queen fling.
It was kind of crazy.
Right now...
We're trying to find...
We're trying to find Toby.
And Toby is maybe British.
Wait...
Maybe British and also...
Really loves Magicorn.
Which is basically...
Pokemon.
Tell them about the chest butt plug.
No, no, no, no.
That's...
That's unconfirmed.
Wait, hold on.
I want to go check real quick.
Before we go in through there.
I want to see...
If maybe...
Because we're...
I don't know where Theodore is.
We've lost that...
We've lost sight of that guy.
My ears just perked up.
Well, there's just a lot of lotion in this guy's tent.
And he plays chess.
I don't even got...
Have you guys heard about that?
The chess player who...
Maybe cheated because he was getting fed answers...
Through possible...
Vibrations of an apparatus up his bum hole.
It's a true story.
Nice jazzy game.
Also your jazzy cover of Can't Say Goodbye to Yesterday is the second...
Search result on YouTube!
We might get it to number one.
No!
Wait, I don't want it to number one.
The original deserves number one.
Oh yeah, there was also some witchcraft.
Guess I've been cheating at chess too.
Oh.
It's not good...
To cheat.
Can we go into our own tent?
No, let's...
Um...
Alright.
Let's go into the spooky sewer.
It's allegedly Minto.
It was never proven.
Yeah.
But in this game also, it was never proven.
Oh gosh, this is...
This sewage passageway is right below the toilet.
I hope we don't come...
Are we in the sanatorium?
No way.
Ooh!
When we're back home, let's watch the new season of Whale Tail.
I'd like that, yes.
Ah, they're buddies.
You know what?
Tomorrow, we should go for a hike, have a picnic, and play some frisbee.
Maybe.
All the naplings came from one hospital to another.
I hope we have our tetanus shot.
The bus ride home will be so fun!
I can get out the travel edition of Battleships again!
Uh, yeah.
Let's not overdo it.
Battleship sounds fun!
What's this?
Oh!
A breaker?
Fuse box.
Very high up.
Impractical.
No dust.
Clean spot.
So it was knocked over recently.
Probably, someone knocked it over so that they could reach the fuse box, so that they could turn on the light to make it seem haunted!
Glasses.
Stained with blood!
I wonder what caused this statue to fall.
A person.
Whoa!
There's a whole set up in here.
I don't know about this, Mr. Duck Detective.
This looks like some villain's lair.
That window.
We must be inside the sanatorium.
I'm so close to the truth, I can feel it!
I can feel it.
The camping chairs!
That's where they went!
The stolen camping chairs!
From the very beginning!
Scaredy croc achieved.
That's uh...
I got this for entering the sanatorium.
Toby's whereabouts.
Toby is in the lake.
With...
Theodore...
Dying...
For secrets.
We're a little clumsy.
We knock a bunch of stuff over.
We're...
Dustless...
Stiff...
Doof...
Yes.
Oh, that's kind of freaky actually.
Uh...
Let's check out the computer first.
Okay, here we go.
MagiCorn.
Yeah.
OS update.
Oh!
Unpredicted restart.
Is that why the lights started glowing?
Ministry of information.
We protect the people of West Canton.
Sarah Blackhurst, age 29.
Goat!
Role illegal resident agent.
Now we don't know who that is.
Camel crush.
Queen!
Here it is.
Come and get your present.
What?
Are these military secrets?
Is this the king and queen?
This is all very dubious.
It is very dubious.
Sarah Blackhurst.
Who is that?
Mint is a goat?
I'm the goat.
I'm the ghost of all time.
The sanatorium.
The sanatorium was set up by...
Was it...
The chess player guy?
Since...
His...
Chess piece matches the...
Of the photo.
Wait.
Oh, nope.
Not...
Oh, it's completely wrong.
Wait, wait, wait.
One more time.
What the...
Is this...
Message coming to or from?
I can't tell.
But then this...
Seems kind of military-esque, no?
So me...
Oh, wait.
Not here.
I wanna do this one first.
Matilda.
No.
Matilda's not...
Queen was Matilda.
This chess piece matches the whole...
Wait.
I didn't...
Oh, this mess...
No.
The notebook.
The famous movie, The Notebook.
Huh...
Does this belong to the goat, though?
Because our goat is Katya.
Oh, gosh.
She looks so scary.
Maybe it does belong to her, then.
Since her...
But did it have a photo?
Which Ryan is in that movie?
The notebook is...
Ryan...
Gosling.
I remember.
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait.
Um...
Hold on.
Didn't...
She have...
The bruise on her arm?
So what...
That...
What does the bruise have to do with it?
Illegal resident...
Sarah...
She's lying to Freddy.
But there's no bruise...
Here?
No?
Oh my goodness.
So many redirects today.
Thank you.
Bossy Moon.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank you so much.
Rock for Robo, thank you so much.
Luan, welcome to Babusha.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Hello.
Ah, I'm stumped with this one.
There was...
Cause I can't say bruise.
What?
Where?
I did not see the shape of the bruise.
In...
Huh?
This...
Matches what?
Wait...
Is it that?
Is it the statue?
For her to push over the statue?
Oh my gosh, it totally is.
It's got that little notch.
Oh my god!
Matches the...
Uh...
The statue...
Wait, no.
The...
Glasses...
Of the statue.
Katya was the one who set up the lair.
Ah...
Gosh, I forgot about that bruise so long ago.
Oh, we have everything here too.
Wait, Toby's whereabouts.
Toby is...
Under...
The lake.
He's drowning!
He's in the lake!
He's under the lake!
He's underwater.
Somebody save Toby!
He is on the lake.
With Theodore.
Screaming!
Wait, hold on.
I think he's probably doing Magicorn things.
He's looking for Magicorns.
So...
So that's what Toby was up to.
Because we saw his little...
His little...
Okay.
I mean...
His Magicorn Go.
I should first figure out the whole mystery of the campsite.
We saw his Magicorn Go...
Before I made any announcements.
Uh...
Phone.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Katya.
Katya is in...
Disguise.
And using a...
Fake...
Name.
This means she is a spy...
For the...
Is it the East or West?
There were two different countries we saw.
The West?
The West.
Haha!
Frederson's girlfriend was a spy for the West?
Oh my god.
Does that mean she was using him as a cover?
That's why she...
That's why she didn't seem like she liked him.
Alright.
Another missing puzzle piece was the location of these secret documents.
Oh my goodness.
Hiding spot.
The military secrets are hidden in the...
In the broken toilet, maybe?
Ah!
Of course!
Why?
Matilda hid the secret documents in the broken toilet!
Why'd she do that?
That's the one place no one would look.
Justice for Freddy!
Alright.
I should first work out the whole case before I do anything about these documents.
Freddy is just like standing there.
And it's like...
He's like sniffing Ducktectin.
Okay.
Blank is Toby's blank.
Because she had a...
I think it's...
I think it's Theodore is Toby's...
Parent.
A fling...
With...
Wait.
Because...
They had a fling with Matilda...
In the military.
Oh my god!
Scandals everywhere!
Time to confront the culprit!
Oh my god!
I had a feeling this won't be pleasant for Fredderson.
Aw, Freddy.
Freddy Fredderson.
What is this about?
Does the doc want to waste our time again?
This better be important.
Okay, it's time for the Ace Attorney.
I know we're in an unusual situation.
We're gonna call everybody out.
I would appreciate it if...
They will stop calling for random meetings!
This one is important, I promise.
Where did Toby go?
What if that capybara took him?
I will get to that.
First, let me explain what happened.
Look at their stance!
Oh wait, I'm sorry, I was walking there.
As a high-ranking officer in the East Canton Army, Matilda Eisenbaum has access to classified information.
She was entrusted with the physical plans for a new military base.
Meanwhile, Katya Ray has been meticulously preparing her master plan to steal these documents.
She found out that Matilda is a huge fan of the Chess Kid.
Which prompted her to become Arnaud's assistant.
What Arnaud didn't realize was that Katya was actually...
Actually a spy!
For West Canton!
Oh my god!
By using Arnaud's social medias...
...that she got close to Matilda...
...knowledge about...
...and made her trust Arnaud enough...
...to agree to a secret transfer of the documents...
...in hopes of getting special, personal photos of Arnaud.
Uh-huh!
Unfortunately for her...
I, the Duck Detective...
...managed to find the secret hiding spot first.
Yeah, but it wasn't boarded anymore!
And this secret hiding spot is...
Over there!
Right here!
In the broken toilet!
Ba-boom!
Are you kidding me?
That's right, Katya!
I got here first!
But that's not your real name, is it?
Yeah, Miss Sarah!
Sarah?
Sarah Blackhurst?
I guess...
I can take this off now.
What?
Oh my god, it was makeup the whole...
Ah!
I don't understand...
Oh, they're back!
Mom!
Check out this shiny honk draw I caught!
Not the honk draw!
What did I tell you about going with strangers?
Oh, my little Toby!
You're alive!
I'm so glad!
You didn't get kidnapped by the ghost!
And you!
You kidnapped my son!
I knew right from the beginning!
Our son!
You're some kind of...
messed up individual!
Actually...
Mom, he says he's my dad?
Is that...
true?
What?
He told him?
It's been so long!
Um...
Oh my god!
Teddy?
When I saw his hair...
I had no doubt that he was...
Toby!
And Teddy!
You've really liked yourself, bro!
Oh my god, the little thing of hair!
Everything was revealed.
But who was responsible for this crime?
Oh my god...
Katya, Matilda, and Arno were all involved in some way.
Katya has been invading Matilda's privacy...
Wait, what crime?
...seeking to obtain sensitive information in the name of West Canton.
Should she get arrested?
Guys...
They're all guilty.
Yeah...
I think we could arrest everybody.
I think we could...
Uh...
I don't think we actually have the legal means of doing that.
But...
I think because she...
She played with our little precious Freddy's heart...
We...
We arrest her!
She is a spy for the enemy.
Of course she needs to be arrested!
Arrested!
Frederson will just have to get over it.
Oh...
Well, I don't think they would stay together.
Matilda was ready to trade military insider secrets for racing photos.
Should she get arrested?
What is that game?
What's it...
What is it?
World of Tanks?
That...
They're constantly posting like actual...
Actual...
Like...
Top secret military specs to make the tanks more accurate.
War Thunder?
Is it War Thunder?
This is the...
This is...
This is what I'm...
This is kind of...
The...
A similar situation I'm feeling...
To win arguments...
On the forums...
It's...
So funny...
How we could...
Okay...
She wanted the photos...
And she did not actually get them yet.
Or rather...
She did not give up the military secrets yet.
We could argue that it was...
Uh...
What's the word?
Intent!
Yeah, that's the word.
Intent.
Yeah, I don't like her.
So...
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Matilda.
Her actions would have caused serious damage to East Kenton.
Steps we take to prove ourselves right to her.
She definitely should be arrested.
Arno was right at the center of the crime.
But failed to report it.
Should he be arrested?
Wait, sorry, what was that?
Oh gosh, I was reading the super chat.
Zero day since classified military documents.
Conspiracy!
Yeah, that's the word I was thinking of too.
Wait, who was...
Oh, Arno.
I don't think...
He didn't do anything.
In fact, I feel like he was...
His only...
Problem was that he...
Oh, he failed to report the crime.
Did he even know what was going on?
Do you go to jail for being annoying?
I think he's the only one in the right here.
He wanted to leave because...
He like...
His...
His tent got vandalized.
His stuff got stolen.
He's just a streamer.
They're all annoying.
All streamers are annoying.
Except my ocean.
Should be arrested now.
He had no idea what was happening.
I don't think there's grounds for arresting him.
He's biased.
All right.
I made up my mind.
I will report to the state police.
Yes.
Katya.
Matilda.
Yeah.
You're sending my girlfriend to jail?
Yes.
She's a spy, Fredderson.
Are you...
Really?
I'm sorry, Freddy.
You're not so...
What about our...
Forest walks?
When you told me...
That you thought my Rubik's cubes were cool.
I'm so glad she's going to jail.
Was...
Everything a lie?
I thought that...
We'd tell each other everything.
I...
No, I...
No...
I enjoyed those walks too.
You can't separate me from my son!
That foul beast tricked me!
She impersonated the Chess King!
I... I'm the victim here!
Mom, what's happening?
What's happening?
It will all be fine.
Toby, soon you'll learn your...
Where you're from.
Why do you have this accent?
Watch the case again.
Oh!
Yeah!
I expected...
Nothing less!
This is so sad!
The truth...
Is an ugly mistress.
Oh my god...
Maybe we shouldn't have stopped!
But it is my duty...
To throw bread to the kind beak...
Of Lady Justice!
He's crying in the background!
Oh, we follow just like everybody else.
96% of players decided to arrest Katya.
74% of players decided to arrest Matilda.
And 22% of players decided to arrest Arnaud.
Katya deserved it!
But after seeing...
Poor little Freddy...
Sobbing like that...
Everyone gets arrested...
Except the duck...
Except the duck detective!
That was too sad!
Oh, that's it!
Wait, what's gonna happen to Freddy?
Do we get a...
Epilogue?
Please!
But maybe...
Maybe he'll...
You know...
I like the ghost fog...
Maybe he'll become a little more hardened after this, you know?
Maybe he'll...
He'll...
You know...
Be a little less happy-go-lucky...
Freddy...
Mmm...
There's after credits, I think?
Yippee!
Future friends!
Cute!
I wanna be one of the voice actors in one of the future games.
Please, happy broccoli pick-a-bee!
Oreo the cat!
Thanks for playing!
Yay!
Oh!
Well, Frederson...
Don't be sad that it ended...
Be sad that it happened at all.
Wait...
Aren't you...
Eugene McQuacklin?
Indeed!
The one and only...
Duck detective!
I don't think there's gonna be a sequel...
Great!
I might as well take you with me then!
Uh-oh!
You're...
Under arrest!
Wait!
What is happening?
I don't think there's a sequel!
I wanna speak to my lawyer!
This is what happens when you don't make your payments, duck detective!
You get caught by the IRS!
Oh...
No!
This is why you shouldn't have called the police on any of them!
True!
Nooo!
Duck Detected to Duck Detainee.
Oh, nooo!
Let's see if we can... if we... choose not to send any of them to jail.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, we have to go through the whole thing again.
Ah, it's okay then.
No ghost was arrested in this episode.
I felt this one was much... easier than the first one.
I remember struggling a little bit on some of the...
some of the things in the first one.
But this one was much easier to solve.
It is a funny game!
The characters are so silly.
Yeah!
What is unstuck?
I don't know.
Let's see.
Nothing happened.
Mysterious.
Yeah, the VA work is so good, right?
I...
I love Duck Detectives' voice.
Oh, if you get stuck on...
...geometry.
For glitches.
I see, I see, I see.
It was really fun.
Great job...
...quacking the case.
I quacked it, Verily.
I quacked the case.
Justice for Freddy!
Wow, we'll have to see if, uh, if there's a third one.
Maybe, maybe, maybe it becomes, like, true Ace Attorney.
You know how an Ace Attorney, Maya, is always getting arrested?
And instead of playing as Duck Detective, you play as Freddy.
Maybe.
You quacked me up.
Detective Pikachu VA.
True!
So true, right?
Yeah, I feel there were...
...a little less ghosts.
I...
The only thing...
The only thing I would want for this...
...is, like, a little bit more of, like, a...
Is it a ghost?
You know?
...kind of scenes.
Like, oh!
This is a little...
This seems paranormal, but it's not really, you know?
But that's okay.
I'm all the paranormal you need!
Ah.
I'm struggling in grad school, but today I managed to run an experiment all by myself, mostly!
Thank you for always being in my head, Minto, especially when it gets tough.
I'm going in next week when I break something!
Yeah!
Congratulations!
You're so smart!
You did it!
And you can keep doing it!
Yeah!
Good job, Finn!
Thank you, I'm not smart.
Well, you're smarter than me.
I'm not in grad school.
I became a streamer!
I convinced my co-workers to go on a ghost tour during our retreat.
What?
That's awesome!
I want to go on a ghost tour!
And then I could haunt the people that are on the tour!
Get them some real good evidence and they'll be like, This place is definitely haunted!
Streaming is a valuable community service.
Happy to do my part for the community?
The ghost tour is St. Augustine.
I want to go there!
They have like, the castles and stuff.
Not castles.
Like, the forts.
But this was fun!
This was a good...
This was...
This was great!
Duck Detective!
I hope there is a third one.
And if there is, I will play it.
But thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
They're fun to check out with the cannons.
Cool!
Cool, cool, cool!
Yeah!
She's so smart!
Call me!
Brains!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Let's see if there's anybody...
Who can I...
Is there anybody that I can redirect to?
I got so many redirects today.
Mataracon is playing Day of the Diver.
And I love that game, too.
So, we will raid to her.
Otumito, everybody!
Thank you so much!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
Um...
Hydrate!
Hydrate, hydrate!
And don't be a spy for the enemy company.
The country...
Or you might...
Or you could...
Whatever!
Do whatever you want!
Hahahaha!
Otumito!
I'll see you soon!
Bye bye!